Do Do,
do,
and four,
three to spillover fell out.
What's going on?
See Ya.
Good to see you too.
Thank you very much for taking me up on
that flight.
I'm gonna.
Tell you what legitimately you changed
the way I think about La.
It's really small,
isn't it?
It's way smaller than you think.
It's a different thing when you fly over
it.
You Go,
oh,
this ain't that big.
Yeah,
that's here.
This is the cause what it is.
I remember when I was still getting my
license and I was doing a night flight.
Right?
Which is insane.
Totally different ballgame.
Imagine.
And uh,
yeah,
because when you're on the ground you're
like,
wow,
it'd be really easy to see everybody
because you're looking up and all you've
seen is the backdrop of the dark sky.
Right?
Right.
But when you get up there,
if someone's below you,
they disappeared into the city.
So that's what.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So anyway,
so we were flying back and I trained
down in Long Beach,
so we were going along the seven,
10 and I just see like all these,
these lights and it was like,
right?
Them like going up and I go,
what's that?
He goes,
I got a pilot over.
oh,
that's the uh,
that's the fireworks from Disneyland.
And I was like,
fucking Disneyland is right there
because in my head it took like two
hours to get there,
hour and a half going down the five.
But it's just like,
because you don't look at miles,
all you do is look at time when you're
out here because there's so much
traffic.
But it's literally like,
oh,
that's like 40 miles.
It's not even.
It's like from Hollywood,
like I would think it can even be more
than 15,
20 miles away.
Like Anaheim.
He's so fucking close.
But I just,
it's just like Irvine Comedy Club,
that's all I think of it.
Just fucking way to fuck down there.
And then you get up in a helicopter and
you're like there and like 11 minutes
going like this.
This is ridiculous.
So,
um,
yeah,
that's awesome dude.
It was awesome.
Yeah,
it was a Malibu when you landed on top
of that little hill there with a picnic
table.
Dude sat it down.
Nice.
I was a little nervous.
I'm like,
all right,
don't,
don't fuck this up with joe here because
he's going to be like Ed Burger.
No,
it's all right.
When he was flying,
when he was the big part when you went
to land,
he wasn't that good,
but I was smooth and then the apocalypse
now.
Shit,
we're going through the canyons.
John.
That was awesome man.
That was so I get it.
That was a fun.
It's a uh,
it's a lot of fun in the,
you know,
I fly mostly with an instructor because
I got the kit and everything,
but every once in a while you got to go
out by yourself just so you know,
you can do it.
But um,
I also,
um,
I'm actually over to overdue to do it,
but I always go out and I do like the
auto rotations and he'll just sort of
chat on flying along.
He'll just chop throttle and like,
it's just,
it's just rolling the Rpms.
I mean rolling the engine down at the
Rpm,
the engine down and then you immediately
have to pick a spot,
you know,
when sometimes you know,
the lower you are,
you know,
it becomes literally what you,
the first place you look is where you're
putting it.
It's really crazy.
But um,
where you would,
where you would point what you're
talking about.
You mean crash landing,
that's an auto rotation means it'd be
basically if you had some sort of
failure problem,
your engine failure,
whatever.
So like when you're flying along in
the engine's working,
it's drawing air into the disc and
that's what creates lift.
But when,
uh,
when you go into an auto rotation,
um,
it's,
it's the air rushing.
You're using gravity,
bringing the,
uh,
the helicopter down,
using that air,
like almost like a fan to keep it going.
So,
and there's a critical point where if
you let the main rotor go too slow,
that's why the low rpm horn comes on,
which is just a nausea and sound.
If you let it go too low,
that when it gets to a point where if
it's spinning too slowly,
no matter how fast you drop,
you can't get it going again,
fast enough to create and you're
basically at that point,
you're in something that's no longer
able to fly your,
uh,
your instructor,
skylar,
skylar a pointed out something that I
didn't know that they have to Redo those
things.
Like every x amount of miles,
they rebuild every hours.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's a,
well,
they have like,
there's all this maintenance along the
way.
They're incredibly maintained because
I'm sure you noticed if you read the
comments,
all people talk about is dying and
aviation.
It's like,
oh,
that's how entertainers die.
It's like,
no,
it isn't.
They overdose.
If you really looked at the graph there
on the ground,
completely safe overdose car accidents
always overdose ranking.
Yeah.
And Shit like that.
And it's just like,
that's mainly how you die.
Like the amount of people that are up
there every day and then nothing
happens.
It's,
it's,
you know,
but there is the,
the,
the fly in the ointment is that this,
there are particularly at the private
level,
there are knuckleheads out there like
this.
People like I think every time I get in
I'm always thinking like,
am I gonna you know,
I don't want to die today.
So I,
I,
I go over all of the,
a whole bunch of shit and you know,
especially if I'm going to fly solo,
I have the whole flight,
I have all my options on,
you know,
where I could land,
if I had a problem,
like that's what you're supposed to do.
I look at weather reports,
I do all of that shit.
And what happens is guys get more and
more confident and their preflight is a
kind of look,
oh,
it looks pretty clear.
And then they go out there and uh,
you know,
this,
there's people who go up knowing that
they can die.
And then there's other people out there
who just like magnum Pi and they want to
fly by waterfalls and shit.
I mean those guys have more fun.
But it's,
you know,
there's definitely,
um,
those are the people that you're
supposed to fly.
There's like two envelopes.
You supposed to fly within the envelope
of what you're flying and then you know,
your skill set so you don't fly into
shit this like,
you know,
like if,
if it's too windy or whatever,
I'm just saying I'm not going.
Even if I could handle it,
it's like I'm not going to have fun up
there fucking,
you know,
riding it out and just,
let the wind do what it wants to do and
don't fight it.
And you know,
make sure,
you know,
you're not flying to fail.
You do is slow down,
you know.
Um,
but you know,
it's there,
there are elements of that.
But like if you look up there versus
what's going on down below when fly,
I always say this,
when you drive on the highway,
it's like you're flying in formation,
you're in the blue angels with a Bun
with nobody talking to anybody.
You have no idea what anybody's going to
do.
People are texting,
they're on medication,
they're fucking hung over their
suicidal.
What the fuck they're doing,
you know,
and then the Saturday you've got to look
out for the guy splitting lanes and the
motorcycles and shit.
It's pretty amazing how few accidents
are actually are there.
It is,
it is.
And what I fly the Robinson,
they get a bad rep saying they're not
safe because they look at the amount of
crashes that they've had.
But it,
it's,
it's because it's a helicopter you can
afford.
So it's inherently a low our pilot and
if you look at it,
it's,
most of the time it's not,
it's not the,
the helicopter,
it's the,
it's the person flying it,
which is why you really have to be on it
like you,
you can't.
Um,
it's,
it's just not something,
uh,
I don't know how to explain it.
It's this weird thing where your level
of enjoyment is way higher if you're,
if you're riding in it,
you know what I mean?
If you're the person flying the whole
time,
you have your life and other people's
lives enhance so that you're not really,
oh,
look at that.
Oh,
I'll get that.
Yeah.
So like,
you know,
thinking things of like,
when we were flying through that Canyon
Unit,
you've done that.
I think in that shit.
I'm looking,
you know,
no one where the wires are and where the
road is because that's all fucking tree.
So it's going to be the road.
So there's those,
you know,
when you're kind of going around a bend,
this certain altitudes and stuff just
it's,
it's boring,
but it's just stuff that you're always
thinking that um,
you know,
I imagine like when you fight this,
that,
you know,
I know with a lot of it's like instinct
and stuff,
but this,
these things that you just don't.
Do you know what I mean?
I don't know anything about finding.
I was her in boxing.
You don't lead with an upper cut that
just,
it's just fucking things you don't think
you see.
A lot of guys when they go to take off,
they do this fucking thing.
Like the nose down attitude.
Like I was taught not to do that because
they do that because it looks cool.
I don't know why they do it.
I mean,
you're supposed to,
like I was taught,
you're supposed to keep it level so that
way if you have a problem,
you know,
you,
you're already in the right attitude to
just immediately enter,
enter an auto.
Like now if I'm fucking nose down and
from too far to the ground,
I'm just gonna fucking go right into the
ground.
Um,
I dunno,
but I mean I'm still like totally a
novice.
I'm coming up on 200 hours so I don't
know a lot,
but I'm super,
super,
super fucking cautious.
And uh,
I,
I make sure I don't go too long without
doing auto rotations.
I used to hate them and now I actually
really liked them.
Um,
it was sort of the way it was explained
to me.
I didn't get it until one day.
I just thought about it and then I got
it and I was able to lock into it
because it's,
it's the same inputs if you were going
in for a landing,
but they broke it down to like four
steps.
Like it was low Rpm,
you know,
lower,
collective,
gentle aft cyclic,
you know,
a look at your trim strings,
you know?
Yeah.
Was a trim,
trim,
airspeed,
Rpms,
and just fucking doing all of this.
And the reality is,
is just like it's the right pedal.
Jesus Christ,
I forgot that right pedal.
So it's all the same.
It's all the same input if you were
going in for a landing.
So all I do,
anytime I hear the low rpm is I just do
that and then I'm locked into it and
then I'm just watching my.
Then I can just watch my rpms.
And at this point I've flown enough
where I kind of know where I'm in trim,
which basically means you're not like
crabbing and you kind of go and straight
and then he can kind of like pick out
your spot and then it becomes fun.
And what's cool is you can do like one
80 autos.
You can turn around.
And what I do like about it is when you
come down to the ground and you can
bleed off all of your airspeed,
that forward motion that's going to
fucking kill you.
And as long as you don't fuck up and
flare and go back up and then drop like
a,
you know,
it's Kinda like a hockey stop was the
way it was described to me.
Just level it out and running shoe going
to drop.
You pull like that.
And these guys land.
I'm like daisies and stuff.
It's,
it's really amazing.
I'm not as good as that.
But like I,
I will do it where,
you know,
worst case scenario,
I might like,
oh fuck,
like get a little bit of a bump.
Yeah.
But I'm going to be all right.
So,
um,
yeah,
I don't know.
Now there's probably a bunch of people
saying I don't know what the fuck I'm
talking about,
which admittedly,
you know,
I still think there's a lot of shit I
need to learn about standup.
So as long as you go into things like
that,
um,
you know,
well,
the fact that you're doing it and the
fact that you learn in a new thing
that's really difficult to learn,
don't you think that that's good for
your brain?
Now I am a big believer in constantly
learning.
It's why I like you as a person cause
you're constantly,
like you're not the Joe I knew three
years ago in a good way.
You're like,
you learn all of this.
You know,
I first met you.
You weren't hunting,
uh,
you were a marsh.
That was the,
you a two dimensional,
you will,
which was amazing because everyone was
just a community.
You will this taekwondo champion,
a stand up guy.
And then,
and then since then you've added all
like the guests that you have on and the
fact that you're able to like talk to
them and stuff is because you've
continued to,
you know,
um,
it's,
it's the same thing with like a comic
who writes his first hour and then just
sits on it for like eight years and all
of a sudden two presidents goes by and
it's like,
why aren't they laughing anymore?
It's like because you're just stuck in
time.
So,
um,
I,
yeah,
I believe in that.
I also believe in
cards,
card games and stuff is good for your
end in any games they say in video
games,
you know,
people like the shit on video games,
but they say video games have a positive
cognitive effect on kids.
Yeah.
That's calculating and move it.
You're thinking fast.
Yeah,
they're hand eye coordination is like
insane.
I guess if some of those games,
if you play them,
I guess,
I don't know.
Well you think about the amount of hours
they're putting into their thumbs.
Just how often do you really use your
thumb and like detailed ways.
Very rarely,
but kids didn't have ridiculous thumb
dexterity.
I tapped out a grand theft auto three is
when I stopped,
which was about 2003,
2002 or something.
I just,
they were just too amazing.
And ours just like,
like
I am nowhere in my career right now.
And this is just dude.
I was walking around was living in New
York at the time and I would playing the
game and I would be walking down the
street thinking about it like what?
I walked into the subway,
you know,
like not thinking about jokes,
thinking how I could beat this next
level.
I remember I played this,
um,
metal of honor game and uh,
they had this thing when you hit the
sniper button,
like the scope would go like that and x
would go like that.
And I,
and I played at one day or one week so
much that when I walked out on the
street,
I was looking at people cross the street
to unlike that at x on my face.
I was just like something about like,
I already,
uh,
I'm not the brightest guy.
You know,
when it comes to like school and shit,
so it's just like I was like,
this is doing something to my brain,
so I kind of,
I remember I came home and I just
unplugged everything but really quickly
took everything off because I knew I was
never going to figure it out and I
didn't have any instructions anymore.
I just stuck it in the back of the like,
well that's it.
I did the same thing with video games
with quake.
I,
I had a real problem when I was playing
eight hours a day,
10 hours a day sometimes I had a t one
line installed in my house just so I
could play with a faster Internet
connection.
This is like 1998.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
I mean there was slow Internet where I
was so I said,
well what's the options?
And so one option is they chew up the
street and put this fucking crazy fat
business line.
Cost me a shit load of money.
And I was like,
let's do it out of fucking business line
that we use at the time you'd use for a
large building.
And I had it just for my house and I
would play video games online all the
time.
And you can play online against people
for the last 20 years.
Oh yeah.
I didn't know that.
We play online teams.
We'd have teams of guys like me and
three of my friends would play against
four other guys and we'd meet at a
certain server and you know,
you could chat and talk to each other.
All right,
you ready to go?
Alright,
let's go.
And three,
two,
one go.
And then the game will start and then we
have these matches.
And it was fun,
man.
It was really fun.
It was really exciting too because it's
all happening in real time.
But uh,
I reached a point,
uh,
somewhere around like the year 2000
where I know one day I played until it
was sunlight until the sun came up.
And you know,
I'm fucking 30 years old and I'm sitting
there.
My hands are sweating.
I'm all fucking caffeinated up.
I've been drinking a mountain dew for
the past eight hours.
And I realized,
I'm like,
what am I doing like this,
you know,
I'm not where I want to be as a comic,
I'm not where I want to be with my life.
And uh,
I'm just sitting here playing video
games all the time and there's no future
in this.
I've been stuck in things where there's
no future before I know what that is.
I felt like that with fighting,
I was when I was 21,
there was a point in time where I was
like,
there's no future in this.
Like I'm just going to keep getting hit
in the head and I'm going to get dumber
and more brain damage and more crazy.
And I'm like,
this is dangerous.
And I realized I'm,
I gotta stop.
There's no future in this.
There was no money in fighting back then
either.
And then I got there with pool.
Same thing with pool.
Like my manager called me up and he
said,
I think you play pool too much.
He's like,
he's like,
I think that you seriously think about
pool more than you do your career.
And uh,
I respect him and he's a very good
friend of mine,
so I had a really,
really poor.
I didn't,
you know,
I didn't take it lightly.
I had to take a deep breath and I was
like,
fuck.
He's right.
I played pool all the time.
It was playing every day.
I have a,
I have a real addictive personnel too.
I do too.
So I get like a,
like how many hours I want to get flying
and then like a things I want to learn,
playing drums and stuff and then it
becomes,
I,
I've had to learn to be like built.
These are hobbies.
Yes,
yes.
Dad First.
And you're a comedian.
Let's sort of priority.
Like the world isn't waiting for you to
know how to play good times,
bad times.
That can sit back a little bit.
But the fact that you're doing that kind
of stuff I think is great.
I love it.
I really identify with you and a lot of
ways when you do that well you get
fucking crazy about drums.
Are you going crazy bro?
Everything.
I just.
Can I just,
I go down,
like I got to learn all about,
like everything came out here.
I got into old cars and then all of a
sudden I was watching this guy,
Eric,
the car guy.
I found him most fascinating because he
would work on like cars of today.
Will you just open the hood?
It's like what is everything and where
the hotter you get it and he's just
taken off all this plastic shit and just
dig in all the way down and he's just
like,
you know,
if you can't remember just video tape
it.
Just remember how it all goes together.
Dude.
One time I forget what the hell he was
changing,
but he had to take the whole front end
of this car off to change something that
I used to be able to change on,
like my fucking 83 Ford Ranger.
I know that guy.
I know what you're talking about.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's in,
it's like he does every electrical.
He doesn't fucking everything and I
would just sit there.
I watched all of that.
I watched all the way back to people
rebuilding like Flathead v eight s and
what made it a flathead and I never got
any electrical that always seemed like
magic to me.
Like I never got into that shit.
I was scared like,
Oh,
you touch it and you get fucking
electrocuted.
But I got all into like watching like,
like somebody rebuild an engine,
like just from the bottom to the top.
And that just wasn't a lot of stuff,
right?
It was like the crank shaft and then
there was the shit that held on the
Pistons.
You put the drop to Pistons in and that
the.
Then there was the intake,
the intake manifold and then the other
was the um,
uh,
the big thing,
the valves gapping the valves that
seemed like our man,
if you fuck that up,
this thing isn't going to run right.
And um,
and just knowing that the firing thing.
And I got into like Torque wrenches and
I learned how to change brakes on like
a,
like old school,
like shoe breaks and stuff like that.
I got all the right wrenches and all
that.
Um,
I don't know how to adjust them.
I know where you do this,
this little slit in the back of the
wheel and I thought you just put them
close to it.
It's right up against the drum.
You supposed to put them on.
And I got totally into fucking breaks
for awhile.
I tried to rebuild the carburetor,
failed miserably because it was really
old and I took off too parts.
It was like warped and shit.
So was that your dodge?
The truck now?
Ford.
Ford,
yeah.
Ford a black.
It's black.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
The thing was brown.
I don't know what years.
Alex.
60,
68.
It was made.
I looked up the vin number.
It was actually made in Canada.
Crazy.
March of [inaudible].
Sixty eight,
I want to say Toronto or something like
that.
Like they,
I guess they had a,
a,
a factory up there or whatever.
So in March of 19,
68,
that thing rolled off and I think it
spent most of its life down south,
like in Georgia.
And you swap the breaks off or
dyspraxia?
I did a,
I,
Chris Titus was the one who helped me
with that.
Uh,
he put a,
I did one side,
he did the other,
but he showed me I was just doing what
he told me to do,
so I had all drum brakes and I wanted to
keep it all original,
but you know,
people were pulling out in front of me
like I had disc brakes and I'll tell you
what,
it's fucking hilarious.
When I only had drum breaks,
I locked him up one time in front of a
bunch of millennials and they've never
heard that sound fucking.
And they all,
they all went like that.
And all I was doing,
I just,
you know,
the light turned yellow fast.
Yellow lights are out here.
I was kind of an east coast mindset like
I can make this.
No,
I can't.
And I just fucking.
I didn't even think I hit him that hard.
I kind of went a little sideways and
then it was fucking hilarious.
It's like this outdoor cafe and they all
looked over and then I just had to
fucking sit there.
It was almost like that already lang
movie,
when he fucking moon,
he moves the crowd and the guy gets out
and just leaves him there.
He's like,
oh,
he was.
He was supposed to keep going.
That's what I felt like I was actually
embarrassed.
I'd probably waved and said sorry.
Those breaks are terrible.
It's amazing.
Nobody died or more people didn't die.
Rather those bricks are used to have a
1970 barracuda that,
those kinds of breaks.
Oh yeah.
No,
just was 71 when I was in high school
and you'd hit the brakes and it would
just skid.
I mean,
there was everything locked up inside
lock breaks.
One of the greatest inventions.
Ms.
fucking incredible invention.
No,
I used to drive my truck before I had
power steering.
I've got put power steering in an air
conditioning.
It was just basically a farm truck and
it was like no power steering three on
the column,
which I still have because I think
that's cool.
And I used,
I got stuck in the teeth of the one
night,
like the fucking,
uh,
you know,
traffic always say it stuck driving
through the teeth of it.
It'd be like between five and seven,
I was coming from Santa Monica driving
over to the fucking laugh factory.
And I literally,
by the time I got to the laugh factory,
I was tired.
Man.
I know I'm an older guy,
but just like shifting and like,
you know,
like when you,
when you're at a dead stop and you just
turning the fucking wave of that and
it's this giant steering wheel to give
you like leverage.
That's why the fucking thing is so big.
And I was just like,
oh my God,
like I,
you know,
do an,
a three point turn in that like my
triceps would be burning.
Not In the best shape,
but I'm just saying it's like I got to
make my life a little easier.
My little
car,
that little red car that I have that
doesn't have any power steering.
And when I,
when I turned thing,
that car is so light and tiny,
it's fucking hard to turn though.
Like when I have to pull into the
parking lot at the comedy store and I
have to back it up so that I could get
out of there quick.
Yeah.
It's a pain in the Dick.
Three point turns are not three point
turns.
So like four or five points.
Yeah.
I wonder if back in the day,
because those,
those original cars,
they had those little skinny bike tires
on it.
It was,
it was just easier to turn in as they
got like heavier and wider.
Well,
you know,
my corvette has that modern suspension
on it,
that 65 corvette and it has really wide
tires,
like the big old steam rollers.
Just for a goof.
I had the power steering taken off.
I'm like,
let's see what it's like to have the
power steering.
It's fucking horrible.
It was horrible.
You'd get a forum workout just driving
around
driving on the street.
Yeah.
You're bouncing around.
It was too much
and change it back.
Yeah.
I love old cars though.
There's something about the idea that
you could fix it.
You could go in there and with a good
book or a good video,
you can actually fix it,
you know,
I know a lot of guys will fix things.
I know guys who have changed their
transmission,
they've gone in there and swap their
transmission now for a new one
balls to take it apart.
And then the patient's like,
I know you gotta ask for help.
And like I just found like it was just
like,
and like,
ah,
I need what tool?
I don't have that fucking tool.
Then you have to order it.
It was really frustrating.
And um,
that was a quick sort of like rabbit
hole I went down.
So I like,
now that I kind of understand how the
whole thing comes together.
Um,
but like,
yeah,
I guess that gets back to the whole,
uh,
going down the rabbit hole,
there's a guy who's got a great video
that you would love and it's on
petrolicious and it's the video called,
I think it's called a car,
one car for everything.
And is this guy,
he's a fiction writer,
writes screenplays and shit.
Never worked on a car in his life.
Decided you want to buy an old porsche,
so he bought like a 1971 porsche and
didn't know Jack Shit about cars,
so he starts learning one called car to
do it all.
That's it.
So this guy puts together this car and
then starts working on it and then takes
his fucking garage and turns his garage
until like a professional workspace,
digs a hole in the ground,
puts a lift in,
in the floor of his garage,
like blaze cement does everything.
This guy married A.
I don't know,
it doesn't seem like it doesn't seem
like.
But he's got that old car.
This is the car.
A beautiful car.
Look at that thing.
I'd love those.
Oh and that's,
you know,
my
71,
it looks like in 19,
late seventies to me.
No,
it's a flat.
No flat hood.
The long hood rather.
The long hood models are like 68,
67,
68 to [inaudible] 73.
That's the name Jack Olson.
It's a really fucking cool video because
this is a guy that didn't have any
background in it.
That's his fucking garage.
He built all this.
He built the whole garage and he
decided,
look,
I just slowly get into it and understand
it and he has different Arrow,
like see that giant wing that's Arrow
that he puts on only when he's at the
race track so we can unbolt it and do
it.
He uses his car for everything.
He uses his car to go get groceries.
That looks like fucking beautiful car.
Those cars are so light to that car.
Cars like 2010.
He flared out the fenders though,
right?
No,
no.
The RSR from that era had flared
fenders.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well they had to have fat rear fenders
and fat rear tires because the engine's
in the back and those things snap around
when you take in turns because the
balance is way off.
Like the engine is hanging out behind
the rear wheels.
It's not a mid engine car.
It's a rear engine car,
which is extremely rare,
like only porsche really does it and so
you get something called lift,
throttle,
oversteer.
When you're in a turn,
you have to keep the pedal on.
You have to keep the gas going.
When you're in a turn,
if you let off the turn,
your rear end just pops out and you get
oversteer you'll spin around in a
circle.
So they used to call the turbos widow
makers because the way they used to have
those old cars,
they used to have those really shitty
tires like that.
Like he's got new modern compound tires
on that thing,
so it probably sticks like glue,
but the old tires were dog shit.
They were terrible.
So you'd have this super powerful
engine,
the weird dynamics where the engine's
hanging out behind the axle.
I never thought about that.
Yeah.
So much fun to drive.
There's so much fun to drive.
So engaging.
I love taking it to the store because by
the time I get to the store,
like my brain's firing,
it's like pop in because I've been
shifted and it's all mechanical.
It's air cooled,
you know,
and it's not a very.
Like that red car is not a very fast
car.
Like a modern car.
Like a tesla is way faster than it is,
but it's what it is,
is a lie.
It's like you feel the gears,
like when you shifted,
put that sucker in a second.
It's very visceral,
you know?
Yeah.
I drove a buddy's tesla one time.
That was fucking ridiculous.
It fast.
Yeah.
No,
my head was Tanglin,
like I said,
blood rushing to the back and he just
had the one motor and every guy I know
that has a tesla,
the handful,
a handful I should say.
Uh,
they all got invited to the factory when
they got the motor on the front wheel
and the back wheel and all of them said
no to that car going,
dude,
I would fucking die if I got that.
It was like almost like super bike
motorcycle fast.
Like a,
like a,
like a racing motorcycle level fast.
It's zero to 60 in like two point
something seconds.
And then they have that new one,
that roadster that's coming out.
That's one point.
Something seconds.
One point something seconds.
Zero to 60.
Yeah.
You're,
you're in a missile.
I,
it's the only way to put it.
Like God forbid somebody's foot slips
off the brake onto the gas.
You're going to obliterate a street full
of people and that's fucking crazy.
It is crazy.
It's bad enough.
Somebody does that on a bike.
You can do that on a car with all that
weight and those tassels.
I heavy as shit because of that battery,
I guess.
Which I didn't really.
I think I would think because there was
no power train or anything that it would
be lighter,
but I guess that is like super heavy
shit and they don't make any noise,
which is even weirder.
So they're coming at you.
You don't even know.
Yeah,
they're kind of lost and I don't know.
I don't like the front end.
There's no grilling.
The front end's boring.
It is kind of boring.
Kind of boring.
Like the new one isn't the roadster
roadster that pull up the.
Can I promote that?
That roadster.
Can I promote the portrays thing?
Fuck you.
Uh,
what,
what do we to February 19th.
The.
What would this look at?
This eighth annual Tesla's new emissions
testing mode will produce loud nasty
farts on demand.
It makes fart.
Added a fart app this week.
Oh,
that's so ridiculous.
It's got seven different parts or six
different fart sounds,
and then one automatic.
You can set it to like different
buttons,
turn signal,
and so it makes sounds and it makes
smell to no smell.
It's just the sound emissions.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
That's just stupid.
Anyways,
to patrice o'neal Fart.
When is the February 19th at the New
York City Center.
And uh,
what do we got here?
I shut off my damn phone.
We got um,
Michelle Wolf.
Jim Gaffigan.
Uh,
I got it here.
Had I already forget.
I'm SIFA sounds myself.
Rich Vos.
It's all coming back here.
Big J.
Big Jay Oakerson.
Gary Goldman.
Chris read a.
that's a fucking hell of a line.
We're going to try to add a couple more
people to it.
It's at the New York City Center.
Tuesday,
February 19th.
Uh,
all proceeds go to his family and it's
been such a great thing like his,
um,
his mom's been able to get a condo and
everything just total because he was
taking.
We basically with that thing we take
care of everybody that he was taking
care of.
[inaudible] believe the mission was
basically all his family should have to
deal with is the grief Brent,
you know,
I always think that that's enough.
And the reason why we continue to do
whatever year is because his family
members are still,
you know,
alive.
And I always hated that when somebody
died and says,
hey,
we do one time,
it was a sack of money trying to make
this last for the next 30 to 60 years of
our lives,
you know.
And uh,
and then also because,
you know,
he was the best standup that I ever saw
live.
And uh,
just keeping his name,
you know,
I always think that when,
anytime somebody says,
oh,
you're one of the top blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And I always think,
well,
you know,
if Patrice and Hedberg and all of these
fucking guys do Freddy Soda,
what he would've done.
Just thinking about Freddy,
I was just thinking about that when you
said that,
that maybe we should do one of those for
Freddy's family.
Yeah.
Freddie was like,
he was a brilliant.
Oh,
when he was,
where he would imitate his dad and shit.
Cardless.
Oh No,
it was like,
yeah,
he would like hurt the crowd.
It was like,
he was like,
oh my God.
Stop.
Stop fucking guy too.
Yeah,
he was.
Every time you saw Freddy Soto is all
about hugs.
Oh,
there's a good dude.
I last time,
last time I saw him,
we
were working in a number,
the aspen comedy festival.
Yeah.
I remember that.
And I didn't see him the last couple of
years.
Maybe I saw him out in la,
but that was the time that I remembered
because we were kind of in the same
group,
Group B,
Group A or whatever.
So,
uh,
yeah,
he was walking around,
I think it was buying something for his
wife or his kid or something like that.
I,
that one.
Jesus,
you know,
you heard so many out of all of them.
He was when I was just like Freddie,
Freddie died.
I couldn't believe the sleep apnea.
Apparently sleep apnea and pills to go
to sleep,
you know,
take ambien.
If you have sleep apnea,
you lock up and you just stopped
breathing.
Sleep apnea is a real fucking problem.
I have it,
I took a mouthpiece mouthpiece in at
night when I go to sleep,
but it keeps my tongue from falling back
on my throat.
A lot of athletes have it.
The bigger your neck gets,
the more muscle tissue you have in your
neck,
the more closes off your air hole.
When you go to sleep,
like there's a lot of meat in there,
most stuff filling the night shift and
dude,
what do you do when you got to get a
barbell and just tied to the side of
your fucking head effective working out.
You just get a big no one can straggle
you.
That is what it is for real like,
well,
someone could definitely still strangle
you,
but it helps a lot.
Like if you get ahold of a regular neck.
Regular.
Next,
just comply.
Please call your next special regular
neck.
I guarantee no one's going to try and
accidentally take that
title.
Regular neck,
regular neck,
Joe Rogan,
regular neck.
It's hard coming up with a good name for
a special.
Are you?
Somebody told me you were doing.
Are we saying that you're going to do
your next one?
Independent,
you're going to do it independent?
No,
I don't know how I'm going to do it.
I'm,
I'm exploring all the options and all of
that.
I'm,
I'm trying.
I was trying to figure out a way to uh,
you know,
because it's just a ton of specials out
there.
We're just trying to figure out a way.
But I mean,
you know,
when was the last time you filmed a
October?
Twenty 16.
but it's like,
am I do?
I Dunno.
Like I don't,
I don't.
Uh,
it's,
it's what it is.
Is the special has changed since you and
I started.
Yeah,
a special was special.
Now what it is,
is it's just kind of an on hour long
advertisement letting people know that
you're still out there and it's like
this just doesn't have documents your
stuff though.
Yeah,
it does,
it does it.
But there's just such a sheer amount of
stuff to see to have like an impact the
way like I was trying to think maybe the
last one that really was just like whoa.
And I would say it would be like maybe
Dave chappelle killing them softly.
Certainly Chris rock bring the pain
where it was just like,
you know,
I'm not saying there weren't ones that
like,
like people talked about,
but like just that thing where like,
do you remember when we were kids it was
just like,
you know,
Friday,
Hey man,
see you on Monday.
And then somehow on Monday everybody saw
or everybody saw dice or everybody saw
Sam kinison on,
on the,
um,
the,
uh,
the dangerfield thing.
And it was just like no one was talking
about it.
And then just like,
there was only so many channels and that
thing just caught enough people's eyes
and you came to school Monday and
everyone was just talking about it.
Like,
um,
you know,
I'm,
I'm still getting fucking tweets from
people saying,
Hey,
I finally got around to watching,
breaking bad,
you know what I mean?
Or like I was talking about the wire one
time,
they were like,
dude,
you,
you could've said,
spoiler alert.
It's like that fucking went off the air
in like 2006.
Like,
how much time do I have to give you to
watch it,
you know.
So,
um,
I still haven't seen the water due.
My Buddy,
his uh,
his son,
the number one thing that he,
he,
he watches.
Is he on his phone?
He's watching one of these guys that
gets paid to play video games.
He watches this guy on his phone play
video games.
Everybody does that.
Okay.
So yes.
So now that's another thing to watch
exact.
Forget about online porn and fucking me
watching Eric,
the car guy and all that.
Trying to,
trying to like find like where you can
like drop the pamphlets of your career
basically to be like,
hey man,
I'm still around.
I think
there's definitely more content now than
ever before,
but for,
in terms of the amount of standup that's
available,
there's never been more great standup
available to watch.
Yeah.
Like think about how many specials there
are now.
I mean,
it's fun.
It's fucking crazy.
It really is.
It is.
Um,
it's,
yeah.
So they're not really specials.
They're not specialists.
They're not specialists because because
it used to be specialist used to be the
top comics,
now arguably it was basically the top
white male comics.
So the fact that they fixed that is a
great thing.
But now
though,
I mean Chris Rock,
Dave Chappelle,
Damon Wayans,
there was a lot,
there was a lot of white guys.
There was a lot of white guys with a lot
of great black guys too.
Really the real problem was women.
There wasn't very many women.
Like women are like
three stations.
There's Apaches,
there's other people out there doing
standup specials.
There's got to be anyways.
But what I'm saying was,
but it was the best,
the best,
where now it's just everybody.
It's everybody,
right?
So,
like I remember when I remember when it
was changing when I was doing a club and
uh,
the feature act was complaining that he
didn't get a half hour special on one of
these networks.
And I'm thinking like your feature act
and like,
what are you,
what are you going to,
you're going to do your whole act and
you're still a feature and you want to
document that.
And it's just like they used to give out
half hour specials when I started out
and it was to like guys who had been on
the road for like 15 years and they will
pick it up from there,
headlining our,
uh,
they will take half of that,
like the best bits from an and then you
know.
And that's somehow through time just
became a feature going up and doing his
whole act.
Well,
Netflix is doing that now.
They have the degenerate special.
They have a big J did one.
Joey Diaz did one.
Christina Palicki did one.
Um,
I'm not saying it's bad,
I'm just saying it's changed,
right?
So because it's,
it's even changed since my last special
that I put out my last advertisement
that I put out a hour long advertising.
Um,
so you just try to figure out,
because everything's just fucking
changing so fast.
You just trying to navigate like where
can I put this in all of this,
right?
That it's going to blink enough that
someone's going to stare at it.
And maybe like,
watch the thing.
I just noticed you fucking lights with
the sky.
That's pretty critical,
right?
Yes.
She was the company that makes those
octo lights.
Shout out to octo lights.
Gavigan did an interesting thing.
He decided not to put his newest one on
Netflix.
He puts it on everything.
It's on Hulu and Amazon.
You can get it on itunes but not
netflix.
Yeah,
he's a smart guy.
Well he just took a chance,
I guess,
you know,
just decided to see what happens if you
just make it available everywhere
instead.
Yeah,
I'd like to talk to him,
see how successful that was.
Yeah.
I love because I'm still working out my
straight.
I'll talk to you off air because I don't
want because it fucks with my ability to
make something happen.
So I'll,
I'll tell you what my idea was,
but that got nixed.
I've thought about doing it and just put
it right on youtube.
I've thought about doing that before was
not getting paid for it.
Just shoving it right on youtube.
Just see what happens.
Yeah.
And Youtube.
Just paying for it and just sticking it
out there because if it is an
advertisement,
what's the best way to get it out there?
Well,
the best way would just be to put it on
youtube and then to segment it into like
little chunks so that people can digest
it in.
People wind up doing that.
I don't think netflix takes them down.
I think when you have a bits up that
like from specials that,
that go up on Netflix,
I think Netflix just let them stay up.
It
just depends on what your,
uh,
what your contract is because you can
work that in.
We did a special with Paul all things
comedy network.
We did a special with him which was,
did phenomenal,
like broke all their online streaming.
Uh,
um,
records and it was great because he was
a guy that they don't really give
special.
Right.
Now,
you know,
who did he do the special for?
Comedy Central.
Oh,
uh,
so the streaming version was really
successful.
Yeah.
I mean he,
he did well on well now trying to get
people to actually just fucking sit down
and watch television.
Like everybody tape you tape shit,
right?
That's just how it works,
which is now if you watch like NFL
Games,
they have this thing now where the
game's going on and all of a sudden the
game slides to the left and then there's
two boxes and the advertising boxes
bigger because they know everybody's
taping games and they're blowing through
it and advertisers somehow can tell if
someone fast forwarded through and then
that they,
the nfl doesn't make as much money.
So now they're,
they're running like this is where they
take these two things.
So you don't really have to look at the
commercial,
you can just sit there looking at the
game,
but then they're telling you about
fucking whatever at the same time.
Yeah,
it's weird.
That's gross.
It's gross,
but isn't.
I mean that's how I make money off
advertising.
It's like my thing,
what,
what's gross is,
is how your uh,
what,
you know,
if you're dumping shit in the water
supply,
if you got like all kinds of like,
you know,
I mean I think they all have some sort
of labor fucking issues.
I would like that still.
I would like to be able to pay to not
have that.
Like if I could Amazon one click,
I'm like,
how much I got to give you for each
game?
Well,
don't have to see that.
Yeah,
but they'll give you.
But what the advertiser will do is their
pockets are deeper and they're going,
they're going to go.
They're going to find like.
What's funny is when the Internet
started out,
all of a sudden you went from watching
seeing all these commercials to like
nothing to now seeing way more than you
ever saw.
Yeah.
Like my,
the worst is when you watch an hour long
youtube video and then all of a sudden
it just stops and you know,
they try to make,
make a nice break and then you just
watched this and it annoys me.
But I'm like,
well,
I do advertise on my podcast.
How upset about this can I get?
Um,
you know,
I don't know.
When you see,
when you look at the line and you see
those little yellow lines on the youtube
video,
we know that's where the fucking ads are
going to pop up.
No,
I didn't know that.
Isn't that how it works?
Yeah.
I mean look,
advertising is what it is.
I mean it's either that or you do like a
Patriot type deal when you have people
contribute like Sam Harris does that,
right?
It doesn't,
you know,
there's a million ways to do it,
but like I don't get mad at advertising
because like I said,
a standup specials me advertising,
then I'm going to be out on the road.
You say that,
but it's not,
it's entertainment.
It's people that watch it.
They can enjoy it.
Like thinking about it
that there's a way also to do
advertising entertainment like way back.
Those less filling tastes.
Great Bud Light Miller lite commercials
were fucking funny.
They were great and you wanted to see
them and you love them or at least I
did.
So yeah,
there's ways,
there's ways to do everything.
They still have some,
some good commercials.
Like what's that insurance lady who's
always in those commercials.
What does that flow flow?
She's,
she's fucking funny.
This funny commercial still,
but it's,
you know,
it's hard.
I know Seinfeld was actually thinking
about opening up an insurance agency at
one point in time because he apparently
likes writing,
stuff like that and he was literally
thinking of an advertising agency.
When I say insurance advertising,
he was thinking about doing that at one
point in time.
Yeah,
but making ads that he was probably
like,
wait a minute.
I don't want to have a real job.
It was like,
how much money do I need?
Time guys like that make me feel normal
with like car collecting.
Like when I went to Jay Leno's place,
he's got 11 buildings filled with cars.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
I see where this goes.
Yes,
I got to give my son.
He has a.
He is,
I've never been over there,
but he has,
he has enough cars to start his own
traffic jam on the.
He could fill up the four or five one
side of it.
I would think he could fill up the
Pasadena rose bowl.
He can fill up the fucking parking lot.
It's ridiculous.
I'll take you.
You want to go?
Yeah.
But does he have been your truck?
Does he have more?
Uh,
uh,
cars then days of the year.
Oh yeah.
Because I know he also has like
motorcycles.
He said he's got that.
That's another one.
I went down the rabbit hole is a.
was it Jay's garage?
Yeah.
Great show.
Oh yeah,
I loved it.
No,
I,
yeah,
I got into all the gas monkey garage.
Jay's garage getting that gas monkey gun
on the show.
Oh,
Richard Rawlings.
Yeah.
I just got an email yesterday.
He asked me,
that guy's a love guy's a fucking right.
I love that guy.
Ask him about my favorite episode,
my favorite fucking episode of that
because he always,
like,
I watched that show so much.
I knew the number was going to come at.
They'd be like,
okay,
what do you want for this gun?
And he always get them to say it first
and then you're like,
ah.
I mean I was,
I was thinking like a five grand and
then he'd be,
oh,
five now man,
I can't.
I mean,
I mean I,
I could do,
I could do like $2,700.
Right?
And then the fucking guy would then go
down to four grand and he would come up
like,
like 300 bucks and he didn't ever get in
the car for like three grand,
like whatever the fuck you want it.
Right.
So one time he went out and he busted
this guy down on like a,
a,
an old trans am or a firebird.
Assam Shit.
I forget what the guy sells it to him
for like fucking,
he wanted like 18 grand or something.
He sold it to him for like 11.
So he fucking gets the car over there.
He's talking about he's going to do
about with it and all of a sudden the
guy's brother calls up and says,
Hey,
that guy didn't have the fucking right
to sell that car.
That's also mine.
You got to,
you know,
I'm going to come down and go,
I got to buy it back from you.
So the guy comes down and he's,
you know,
asked him what he wants for it in
Richard's just.
I mean I was thinking like 20.
And the guy goes,
he goes,
dude,
you bought it from my brother.
I know what you paid for it.
He actually got embarrassed.
He's like,
Oh man,
that's the only time I ever saw him get
like embarrassed.
He wasn't,
he just went into like his,
his thing and like,
I swear to God,
like watching that show,
like you get better at negotiating and
like,
uh,
and like occasionally he does like these
sketches to where he,
he'll do like a character imitating like
an old school used car salesman and you
just how good he does it.
Cause you know,
it's like he's a performer or an act or
anything.
How good he does.
It's like this guy is like,
this is just in his blood.
He's just been a car guy.
He's been flipping cars.
I'm trying to,
I'm seeing the show in a minute.
But like he used to talk about how he
uh,
you know,
by the time he was 19 he was on his 30th
car or something.
Like,
he was just like,
I like that car,
I'm gonna buy this car.
Like that one.
And even just every month would just
flip them.
Those cars.
There's something about those shows that
if those an auction shows or anytime,
like a pawn shop shows that something
about wanting to know how the deal plays
out,
you know,
that is so compelling for people.
There's something like,
and I'm a moron,
I'll just sit there staring like,
how much are they going to get?
How much they're going to get for that?
Yeah.
Who that civil war coins,
what are those worth
and how much they busted down and just
like,
yeah,
that Guy Richard is probably the best
I've seen.
He's the most entertaining because he's
like a fun guy to watch.
It's a performance.
Yeah.
He's like,
ah man,
I man.
I was thinking,
Oh man,
I don't know.
Yeah.
And then he goes up there and he pulls
out this giant Wad.
It's like,
dude,
you had it,
you had the money.
They look.
I asked to sit there and watch it.
Then he kind of makes fun of him
afterwards,
you know,
we can kinda make like a funny way or
whatever.
But um,
it's a funny thing to that how appealing
that is to men.
Like I bet if you looked at the number
of women who watch those car shows
versus the number of motor trend has a
channel now they have their own channel
and I guarantee you that 97 percent
dudes and three percent women
complaining three percent women going,
what the fuck are you watching?
Like if you looked at the actual
numbers,
like what is it about cars?
Like girls can drive cars,
girls drive cars all the time.
Girls liked cars.
They don't like cars with guys like
cars.
It just.
Most of them.
Generally speaking.
Yeah.
Outside of like Danica Patrick and few
psychos.
Yeah,
I met her one time.
I saw a picture with you.
She did.
She took me around the Indianapolis
Motor speedway
coming down that straight away and
seeing like you know,
where they have the leaderboard and
everything was iconic and I've been to
that race a couple of times so it was
crazy fast.
Were you going.
She ended up,
she only went like half the speed of
what the car,
how fast they would be going to
somebody,
and we got up to maybe like 1:40,
but we were like going around turns and
like my face is doing this,
but what I loved about her was she had
like a test pilot vibe.
Yeah.
Like she came up and was just vice,
like,
handshake and shit.
Beast.
Yeah.
It was pretty.
Uh,
you guys are.
Yeah.
She was just totally like,
a little different than her sunglasses
in my sunglasses.
I definitely,
I've passenger sunglasses.
You know what he's talking about?
They look the same.
No,
no,
no.
Those are like right off the fucking
shelf.
What's wrong with your sunglasses?
Verse Hers,
like you'll see it.
I tell him the details.
Come on man.
That's like me.
I probably,
you know,
your crescent kick probably looks the
same as fucking some guy.
A strip mall to me
literacy's a crescent as one of the
rarest kicks anybody ever pulls off.
It's leftover from the eighties,
whatever.
Um,
but that's kind of legit.
Crossing kicks,
kind of legit.
I thing about Mika is after awhile it
just all becomes like shelby toxins.
Yeah.
And Hammy,
Hammy Kudo.
We get a Hemi cuda coming up and plum
crazy.
Those fucking things are too much.
Do you buy those things for a million
dollars?
And when the car came out was like 20
grand.
I mean not even,
but I like,
I like weird shit.
I like,
you know,
I want to get a 76 GMC rv.
That's what I want to go on the road
with.
And then they had,
this thing was,
I think it was called Palm Palm,
desert green or something like that.
It was like this total Ron Burgundy.
If you click on the interior and that
thing was way ahead of it's time,
it's time.
It's amazing.
Look at that fucking piece of shit.
That's not a piece of shit.
That's fucking tremendous swivel.
Oh my God.
Tell take something.
You walk off stage and get on that
fucking thing.
You feel like a king.
You got a driver.
What do you give a fuck?
You don't give a fuck about anything.
I can be on the road forever and that
just making eggs on that little stove
top.
Now you're in there drinking.
You're doing what you want.
You watching goodfellas or fucking
anchorman.
That is pretty beautiful.
It's so.
Well it's an experience to your riding
that thing.
That's a retro experience as not just a
truck.
Yeah.
That thing I,
you know,
my wife Nixed it.
What are you going to put her in the
fucking drive and we'll keep it.
I don't need it.
She was right.
My wife's always.
Not always,
but mostly women don't like when you
collect shit,
like where are you going to put that?
They don't like that.
You get too many things.
I have the reason why I got this place
collection here.
Oh yeah.
Nobody could say nothing.
The spot on says nothing.
No,
but then it becomes.
You spend more time down there.
Then you don't though.
I got it.
I got it nailed.
I figured it out.
Get up early.
You're being such a jerk.
That's why they don't have a point.
I don't.
I actually,
I can actually refute your opinion,
your point or whatever.
It's so universal too.
All we would have that response like,
the fuck is wrong with you,
and they.
We had a highway.
That's it.
Well,
imagine being them watching you imagine
being a woman have taken care of your
children.
You know,
you give birth.
You had this little tiny infant and then
financially you're relying on this
fucking maniac,
so they're flying helicopters and fixing
cars.
I know playing drums all day.
He's like,
what are you?
As long as the money keeps coming in,
they can't say anything,
but they're like,
what the fuck are you doing?
The end of the day,
you married an eight year old,
wouldn't marry a comedian.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
You're lucky.
We're not drug addicts.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I'm,
I gotta.
I gotta work on myself,
man.
I got fucking,
you know,
I,
I just,
I am a difficult person to live with.
Evidently.
I didn't realize it,
but like I'm now looking at it honestly
stepping back and look.
I go,
yeah,
I can see that.
I can fucking see that.
I've thought about it.
I'm definitely difficult,
but if you don't think about it,
that reminds you about it.
Yeah.
Imagine relying on me.
I mean I'm reliable.
Like I want to be responsible.
If you,
you could have married the me that
worked in a fucking warehouse,
that I would have been the same thing,
you know,
and we would be in a studio apartment.
Here's the deal though.
One that married yet they would've found
someone better.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If you were just fucking off,
never got your shit together,
you know what it's about.
Limit to is their ability to move on.
Yeah.
Like I've,
I've always said like if I have a
fucking died,
how quickly all my clothes will be at
down at the goodwill,
you know,
and she'd just be like,
sell the house that's just burned some
sage.
That was interesting.
Alright,
well next step to the plate.
All my discussions with biologists and
people who study like w what's Gad,
sadly,
what is his discipline?
Behavioral Psychology.
But he studies Gad said,
is that his last name?
It's his fullness.
A D,
g,
a d.
that's his first name.
Gad S A,
a d is his last name.
Is it?
Does it rhyme?
Does it also Ronnie's Canadian
evolutionary behavioral scientist.
Brilliant guy.
He was so in Lebanon.
Does his name still rhyme?
That's a good question.
Is there anywhere he can know me?
My name is.
Gad said.
Now he calls himself the Godfather.
He's great.
Oh,
so he just steered into it.
He's a great guy.
I can imagine these 13 but brilliant.
I last talked to you about why would you
name me
Gad?
Sad.
I don't think sad means the same thing
over there.
You know,
different language.
The end of the day it rhymes.
There's no country you can be on.
You can be on that fucking little island
with a shot.
That guy with the arrows and they get
they're gonna.
Make Fun of.
You should probably kick you off the
island can.
You can't name.
You see some of these celebrities.
Some of the fucking names.
They named their kids.
It's just like,
don't you remember school?
But you don't remember how fucking mean
kids were.
Why are you giving the plate?
Painting a fucking by getting your
creative.
Yeah.
Have a meditation room.
Fucking don't do that with the name.
Oh,
give them a nice bill name.
William.
This is folding chair Johnson.
People need to express themselves.
They do it through the naming of their
tools.
Children.
My other favorite thing that what they
do is when they fucking,
they put their political agenda on them
like the kid doesn't even have a fucking
chance.
Like this whole thing,
like gender roles.
They bs by the way that my little
experience being a dad,
going to kid birthday parties,
they.
Those kids are not old enough for that
behavior to be learned through.
The kids come.
The boys show up.
It is fucking brave heart.
They come over the fucking hill.
The girls are social.
They're sitting there.
That kind of that taking things in in
our kids.
Boys come in,
they fucking dude.
We were at one on Saturday and there was
this.
This kid was hilarious.
He looked like A.
Bobby Hurley is a point guard,
right,
and he was playing this game.
He had like this ball and he was using
his.
His,
his forums is a bat and he was hitting
it.
Then you would catch it,
then he would throw it between his legs.
He was doing all this other kid hand eye
coordination was great for his age,
so over in the corner where I was
sitting with my daughter was these
little like sort of like cushions that
someone had put together like three
piece thing and made it into like a
little chair for.
So an old person like me could sit down.
So I stood up because I was worried that
ball was going to hit,
so it's kind of guarding that.
So he went over and got the ball at one
point and just seeing the chair there,
you know,
all built like that.
He just saw it and just kicked it,
just destroyed it.
And then continued on.
I was thinking like,
why did he do that?
Because he's a boy.
He's a boy.
Yeah.
We like ruined shit.
Well you got a lot of energy.
Little kids like need something to do
that's physical.
The little bodies have the little little
batteries overflowing with energy.
That shit was all about like grabbing,
throwing,
breaking,
breaking.
Yeah.
Do you remember being a kid?
Yeah,
I already did that.
This whole thing of like,
like,
well women aren't aggressive like that
because you know,
a slow standards.
Yeah,
I think it's,
they're aggressive in la.
I think that they,
they literally from like just survival
shit.
They are looking at like,
all right,
that's what I have to compete with.
And there are,
you see them looking at the boys who
appear to be dominating and what they
are is they're actually showing all of
their carts and the little girls are
already taken and in breaking them down
knowing,
well I can't get physical with this
person.
I can't like dominate this person
physically.
This is definitely.
And they just immediately stuck on,
like that's why they're fucking smarter
than real,
I think.
No,
did I lose you somewhere in there?
I don't necessarily think they're
smarter
going on is that uh,
men have different DNA in the genes or
aggressive
men are to be doing reckless shit.
Right.
That's,
I'm just saying it's nice to run society
didn't sit down and watch three cereal
commercials and then be like,
oh,
I need to be fucking this.
I just think that's,
that's just some bullshit that adults
come came up with and judge
as adults,
it's almost always women.
It's women that think that there's
something wrong with the way men are
raising their sons.
They think there's something that like
this idea of these men raising these
kids and these kids being aggressive is
because of the way they're being
coached.
That's not true.
It's just that's just a part of being a
boy.
This is a shit ton of studies of people
wanted to actually look at the science.
I mean if you leave boys alone with toys
and girls along with toys,
boys will gravitate towards trucks and
fucking,
you know,
things that they can hit and smash and
girl sit down there with little teacups
and they play with dogs.
It's natural.
Just a 100 percent natural.
There was a documentary on babies.
You know what they.
Bees are gender neutral,
raising their kids
gender neutral,
so they don't call them a boy or a girl.
And my thing with that is there's no
way.
You're not saying to your son,
you're sure you don't want to wear the
dress.
And then the kid wants to fucking have
wants to parents' approval.
Yeah,
I didn't want that football.
I guess I wanted the dress and it's just
like,
like I said,
you know,
my kids barely two.
So what the fuck do I know?
I'm just saying my limited experience at
kids' birthday parties is not even how
it was ever even questioned that.
Like they're too fucking too young.
The fucking year and a half,
two years old.
Like you're telling me that society has,
they have,
it's ridiculous.
But it's,
it's usually women that want to push
this.
And men who are pitches.
It's like these,
these men that don't like,
they don't like aggressive man.
They don't like manly men.
And so they,
they push it as well.
It's not because they're aggressive and
they're controlling and they want to run
shit.
And that's because that's the thing
where like if you really look at their
agenda when they say the future is
feminine that's not inclusive and
they're.
And they're all about,
I'll make this more inclusive.
It's like,
no,
let us in so we can take it over and
then we'll push you down.
Is is the psychology of the kind of
person that goes after that?
Someone that's after like power.
I'm not saying the average woman is like
that.
My wife is a feminist and she's
intellect inclusive shit,
but like people who are spearheading
stuff like those people are wired the
same way.
Like you know,
I mean a dominator is.
Yes,
yes.
And there's gonna be no room for you.
It's gonna be like think the way,
like a lot of that that's so called
progressives.
Extreme left is think the way we think.
Save what we say.
Oh,
we will fucking destroy you.
Pull up that tweet that I retweeted
today.
The David Pakman retweet.
David Pacman's is liberal progressive
guy.
This woman posts on twitter,
she would never vote for a man or a
white,
a white man or white person,
white male.
Why?
Someone is white or male.
He says that's racist and sexist.
It is.
So she blocks them on twitter today.
She called Boston College demanding that
they not have him back as adjunct
faculty.
It's crazy.
So this woman post this and he points
out that it's racist and sexist,
so she blocks them and she tries to get
him fired.
Okay,
this is why that whole thing is fucked
up.
Okay.
Because he's acting like white people
exist on an even plane,
which is,
which a lot of people try to do.
So it's like he's not necessarily he
just saying that what she's saying is
racist and sexist because she's
determining which is going to vote for
based on tire on the race.
But there's other elements involved like
the level of that white people.
Not saying all white people,
but white people have fucked over people
who are not white.
Forget about poor white people who they
fucked over.
So you understand that.
But they're both.
Right?
But then like the fact that she then
takes it to the point that because he
had the audacity to have a difference of
an opinion,
that that's the thing now in that now
we're going to destroy you and you can't
be on this thing.
And then the other level of that is how
the corporate entities are so afraid
that one fucking nickel is gonna roll
out across all of this shit is just a
paper tiger until you get the big
behemoth to listen to you and this,
all of these,
these fucking things from award shows to
this bullshit that someone just needs to
be like,
listen,
this guy already apologized.
This is,
this is an old fucking thing or a look,
you just had a difference of opinion
that,
you know,
this isn't the first time you're going
to say something and somebody's going to
disagree with you.
That doesn't mean that this guy can't
come back.
Um,
you know,
and you obviously because of some shit
that's happened to you have an extreme
opinion about this guy because of the
color of his skin.
It's like there's so many fucked up
elements to that that.
But for some reason you can't,
like if you address that on any level,
um,
then you're part of the problem.
And it's not just part of the problem
that she's trying to get him fired.
She's trying to get him fired for
pointing out that something is racist.
I'm saying if you say what I just said,
try to look at it three 60.
Oh yeah.
And as much as I can,
which is why I love South Park is
everything that they do.
They do at three 60.
Right.
And uh,
so I learned a lot from that show by the
way.
They look at stuff like that because I
don't fucking know everything,
but even just to try to be like,
well,
hey,
you know,
insulted,
salted them a little bit.
I understand what you're saying and blah
blah blah.
You can't fucking do that anymore
because then something you all part of
the fucking problem.
And no,
it's really good.
Crazy crazy.
Got to the point like,
I've seen like a name names,
but I've seen like a tweet from a fellow
comic telling comics what jokes you
shouldn't talk about this topic.
It's like who the fuck are you?
Let's say there's already been enough
people doing that.
You're going to do like cannibalism now.
Have you ever seen comics say real
comics?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
everybody has their opinion on somebody
fucking act,
but I mean,
yeah,
that's ridiculous.
That's not a real comic.
Um,
well,
I wouldn't say that they are a real
comic.
They just have an opinion.
I don't agree with thinking fuck off.
I mean,
I mean trying to have less
confrontations.
I understand in my life here.
That kinda shit drives me crazy though.
What,
what drives me most crazy is this
bullying,
what she's trying to get him fired.
She tried to get him fired for having an
opinion on something that she publicly
stated.
One of these,
the,
somebody running one of these things has
to be like,
you know,
and it can't just be private.
It has to be a public tweet to say that
this is,
it's just going too far in this fucking
thing where you have a difference of an
opinion now and they're just gonna,
you know,
take your fucking job away.
You know,
I ran into this shit,
you know,
when,
uh,
when the,
me too stuff first started coming out,
people would try to like,
you know,
you had to tweet the right fucking thing
and if,
if you said anything sort of,
oh it's,
let's look at the evidence,
God forbid you fucking said that.
It just became like this whole part of
the problem.
Then they would try to take you down or,
or,
or someone you were,
you were friends with or doing a show
with a represented by.
They would try to do like that pressure
to try in.
And it was just like,
you know,
I have to say,
I was like,
no,
I'm not doing that.
And then it just goes away because you
don't have to fucking leg to stand on
people that are doing it.
It's a small percentage of
unbelievably small,
unbelievably small.
And the comics,
it's like we're literally running for
office.
We're out there campaigning for this
election that never happens.
And you're going through red states,
blue states,
you going through fucking everything.
And the general consensus of people is
like,
dude,
that was fucking crazy like that.
That doesn't make sense,
but no one wants to say it because
they're going to get steamrolled.
And
I saw what happened to Matt Damon.
Matt Damon said we have to make a
differentiation between the Harvey
Weinsteins in the world.
And then someone who like Aziz Ansari,
he goes on a bad date,
there's a big difference between those
two.
And they attacked him and they tried to
get them pulled off of that movie.
Ocean's eight.
Yeah.
And they were acting like that,
like killing somebody versus stealing a
car versus walking like literally the
whole judicial system is based on what
you did is your punishment.
Your parents do that.
Right.
You know what I mean?
You're bad was what you did.
Yeah.
That's all.
That's what that sounded like.
That.
Yeah,
exactly.
We live in a world now where I have to
be measured in the way that I say that.
What he said,
you know,
affected me how I heard it.
And then also this is just a template,
gold fucking bald,
white male.
And they,
did they go in that route,
it's like you,
you literally sound like what the fuck
you're against and it's,
it's a,
it's not gonna last and I feel like it's
like the end of the winter and people
want to go outside and get some sun on
their face.
And you didn't like.
No,
no,
like taking people by the back of their
fucking neck and fucking shoving their
face in the shit that you can't sustain
that.
No,
you can't sustain.
It doesn't,
it doesn't work.
You don't get people to change by
yelling at them.
It doesn't work.
Bombing them like what the fuck we're
doing with like,
yeah,
that's not all you're doing is you're
just building up resentment and more
people want to fucking take you down.
So that's.
They don't understand psychology.
So what they think is this is their
time.
This is their time to get back at men is
there their time to yell at men,
this is the time to where the future is
feminine tee shirts.
There's a time to take their stand and
they will say,
did you not see the women's March?
I saw a bunch of people walking.
Right?
Listen,
I'm not saying the points that they're
making don't need to be made.
I'm not saying that their complaints are
not just.
It's,
it's the execution of it.
Yes.
Where it's like you're going to go
through intimidation and destroying
people like exactly people's careers and
people.
You have to publicly
apologize.
It's so.
It's like that's bullying people.
Yes.
Some of the biggest bullies right now I
can't believe it because I'm a lefty are
on my side of the fucking fence and you
know when someone's on your side of the
fence and you'll looking at him like you
sound like a fucking crazy person.
That's when you've entered.
What was your special strange times?
Weird.
Yeah,
like it's like it is strange.
It is strange because it's,
it's they feel like they're justified
because they feel like with the maniac,
like trump in the office,
that they have to do what they have to
do to change the world,
but you don't change the world by
yelling at people.
It doesn't work that way.
And there's this real points to be made
is real points about.
I couldn't imagine being a woman working
in an office with a bunch of guys trying
to fuck you all the time.
It's got to be a goddamn nightmare.
I can't imagine having a bunch of bosses
that literally tell you,
you suck my Dick.
I'll give you a race that happens.
Yes,
fucking.
It's got to be hell.
I get it.
I mean,
you got to be like an eight though.
Eight on up to deal with that everyday.
I mean,
let's be fucking honest.
You know what I mean?
There's really,
there's really six is out there that's
really good.
If you've got a lot,
got a nice ass.
Just say it.
You know,
it's just like some of that shit is
fucking,
you know,
it's,
it's.
I always viewed it like,
like you ever watched like the behind
the scenes of like a prison in the first
thing every guy thinks is like,
how the fuck would I not get raped in
their exact women have to think that
just fucking walking down the street.
So that's how I wrap my head around to
be like,
wow,
okay.
Like what they're saying is like,
because I don't
like,
like
one of the arguments,
not like that doesn't make sense.
What doesn't make sense to me is the
children of the corn torches burning and
just go like,
um,
the way that,
I mean a lot of people,
they do that with like a,
our foreign policy.
Like this whole fucking thing is
bankrupted this country every August now
that just shut down the government which
has just become normal and all they do
to,
to make it like,
okay is they just raised the level of
debt that we legally can take on or
whatever.
And it's like,
all right,
let's do this for another year.
And if you question any of that,
that means you don't support the troops
and you're a fucking piece of shit.
You need to get the fuck out of here.
And it's like so much stuff doesn't make
sense to me.
Like I just saw,
um,
Michelle Obama,
they had this fucking tweet of her
wearing these glitter thigh high boots
and said sets twitter on fire with their
$4,000
fucking boots.
And it's just like,
you know,
the top question where she got that
money,
the president makes 500 grand a year.
She blew four grant and thigh high boots
and don't even talk to me about the
fucking book deal and all of that shit.
That fucking guy.
His first like to,
you know,
public speaking engagement,
things were like with major banks and
you go out on the road,
thousands of dollars and all these guys
are like,
fuck it.
All these fellow Americans are upside
down in the house from those fucking
banker comes who did not get,
did not get punished in 2008.
They all see me.
We'll talk about like people who should
have their fucking lives burned down.
Those people and these guys that they're
in,
they have their faces in the same
fucking pig trough.
It's the guys with the red ties and for
whatever reason,
like
I don't.
And I don't know why.
Like they get a pass.
Exactly.
It doesn't make any sense.
And then more serious shit.
Like drone strikes,
more,
more innocent.
Civilians were killed with drone strikes
during Obama's administration.
I know.
And that's why they're telling me you
fighting terrorism,
why you're creating more of it,
because all I would want to do is just
get revenge.
Exactly.
And uh,
you know,
I have
plastic ways of how to get the fuck out
of there.
How do you do it?
Well,
I mean,
I'm not saying the air would be cleaner
because I don't know what,
like when you throw a tesla battery into
the fucking ocean,
what that does to it.
I'm sure it's fucking horrible,
but I know that there are a one stop
shop over there in the Middle East.
They got oil and that's it.
You know,
I always compare them member that kiosk
and like the South Shore Plaza in
Boston,
that was something,
it was a place called wickson sticks.
All they did was sell candles,
which just seemed like a really
vulnerable business or pewter pot first
they just sold muffins and then they
started doing full breakfast.
Well they'd like a pewter pot that just
selling muffins.
So if we stopped buying muffins and we
had enough oil here,
if we switch to solar power and all that
shit and all the windmills are ugly and
I know it's probably just as much
fucking bat on the environment,
but what it does is it gets you out of
there in bankrupts them and then they
don't have the money to funnel through
the Mos to,
to,
to fund the terrorists.
Well,
the United States is exporting oil now,
which is crazy.
I mean we,
we,
we have a lot of oil,
right?
And especially through,
you know,
I'm just saying.
But if you ever suggested that.
Yeah.
Which I think I just did,
I think then for some reason I don't
love my country and I'm trying to solve
it.
I'm a frugal guy,
you know,
I don't fucking know.
I don't spend beyond my means and you
know,
uh,
I don't like debt and that type of shit.
I don't know how the fuck these guys.
I think that's why the president ages so
much,
um,
well then don't go to sleep.
The pressure you imagined,
the dead bodies,
everything,
all of that.
A pitch is knowing how everything really
works.
Oh yeah.
Trump doesn't seem to mind.
He just takes an extra adderall.
Keeps on trucking.
He doesn't seem like he's all the
scandals.
That guy seems completely because I
think he,
he's,
he's a certain sick mentally that it
doesn't.
It doesn't get.
It doesn't get in because he hasn't aged
at all.
Now granted he's got all that white
stuff around his eyes and he,
you know,
I don't know what he's doing with the
hair,
but the hair is usually the telltale
sign,
but I think it's one of the only
presidents that,
you know,
it's like half of that shit's probably
from a doll,
like who knows where that got enough
money to do like a transplant at this
point.
Right.
You can't do a transplant on that thing.
It doesn't have any.
He doesn't have any donor area.
What do you mean he's got it all in the
back.
That's.
No,
he doesn't ever see what happens when it
flies up in the back.
When the wind hits it,
the back's all balled.
All because he probably did the original
plugs and they didn't take.
Who knows what he's got going on back
there.
He's got chaos going on back there.
You ever seen it?
Yeah.
I mean he's the president and his hair
flops up,
but you ever seen the video of him?
It looks like he's a guy wearing a
demon.
The demon mask.
It's very wispy wispy like it's missing.
Look like,
look like,
you know,
it'd be nuts if he gets a second term
and he shaves his head,
that would be nuts and he would just
look like the most evil fucking do
whatever.
Like that would be like if you've got a
second term shaves,
his head starts doing intermittent
fasting,
lifting weights gets on steroids,
drops down to about a buck 90 jacked.
Yeah,
I mean that would be.
I think yeah,
it's definitely A.
I don't know.
That's why I'm trying to just in my own
little fucking world,
I'm trying to chill out more and I'm
trying not to fucking uh,
there's just,
there's enough yelling.
I don't think that they need it from me
now.
I think more mocking and laughing than
yelling for sure.
But when you see enough of those,
the future is feminine tee shirts and
you see enough hypocrisy and you see
enough people trying to take people out
for commenting on what's sexist and
racist and trying to get people fired.
Like it's a time of outreach across the
board and you have to respond a little
bit.
You have to let people know,
hey,
this is fucking ridiculous.
Like there's.
There's a certain obligation,
especially comedians have as a social
commentator.
You see some stupid shit if you're not
commenting on it,
they're skewed.
Choose to go that route.
Some people just like,
I'm just going to let you forget your
whole work week and I'm just talking
about a bunch of shit.
Small stuff,
like a Seinfeld type stuff.
Yeah,
I mean some people don't comment on
anything that's controversial.
Some people,
they'll go their entire career.
But what I've always loved about
Seinfeld is like if you really listen to
him,
he has contempt.
I said this on the comedians and cars.
He has contempt for like 90 percent of
the things.
This anger underneath this shit.
Brian Regan's like that to Brian Reagan
used to do that fucking bit about the
cattle prod,
you know the walk,
run a walk stand line on the,
on the bucket,
the moving sidewalk at the airport.
When he would act out the cattle prod
that he wanted to fucking do.
I was just like,
there it is.
There it is.
He's one of the nicest fucking guys
ever.
Brian Regan,
he is so nice.
He's an unbelievable.
Just decent a fully formed human being.
He really is a great guy.
He also knows when to get onstage,
when not to get onstage.
If he's drunk,
you won't get on stage.
The other day it was at the store.
He was hanging around.
I had my show in the main room and I
said,
Brian,
you went to a set.
He's like,
thank you,
but I've had too much to drink.
It was in the back bar.
Little bit split up and he just said,
I just don't think it's a good idea.
Especially because he's got that squeaky
clean act.
If he goes up there,
there's fucking conc hey,
can't.
You just can't.
I've only twice in my life I've been on
stage drunk once was an Ireland.
Oh,
that's a good place to be drunk.
Yup.
And then the uh,
that's not doing the kilkenny festival
long time ago.
And then another time I had gone to a
red sox yankees game,
got drunk at the game.
I thought it was sober and somebody
texts me as I got back to the city
going,
hey,
you want to do a spot?
You know,
I got off the subway one do a spot.
It was like,
yeah.
And I thought I,
you know,
when you're so drunk that like,
just drunk fill sober.
And I got on stage and I was just like,
oh shit.
And I really had to slow down.
I was like slurring fucking always gone
on people immediately.
Everything I've learned as a comedian I
was like,
I like opened micro energy and the whole
crowd reacted that way and I had to kind
of slow down and get it going.
I don't even think I did my time.
I was like fucking sweat and my mouth
was dry.
It was just like,
alright,
that's it for me.
That was my closing bit.
That's it for me.
Yeah.
So I never did that again.
Yeah,
it's a,
anything that slows your brain down,
it's not the best.
Yeah.
But a little buzz.
It doesn't hurt anybody just a little
bit.
Uh,
I don't drink you like one drink.
You don't drink.
I know you don't like anything?
No,
I don't actually,
I have like a rule that I used to.
We used to have like a drink before you
go.
Never ever.
Not even adult drink.
Nope.
Never.
Did I think you did no confusing you
with somebody?
Maybe so.
I know.
I'm like,
I'm kind of just,
I don't know.
I was,
I drank too much,
you know,
I was just drink too much and then I
just take some time off.
So I'm just taking time off from booze
and right now I know you got on a big
diet kick for awhile.
You've got down pretty light.
Dania,
you go pretty heavy and then you lost a
ton of weight and he developed abs
again.
I got four out of the eight.
I got halfway there.
Good.
I got halfway there and then uh,
then I had a six week run on the road
and it just fucking sucks,
man.
I ate perfectly.
I wasn't drinking for like two months
now,
almost three months and then six weeks,
six weeks and you just fucking,
you know,
it's just,
it's just not fair.
It's not fair that there's no way in a
healthy way to really lose like five
pounds a week.
But you can easily put on six.
No problem.
No fucking problem.
Especially in like New York.
You could just fucking,
you could do it.
You can lose five pounds a week if you
really have the weight to lose.
I was going to say like I was going to
say 10 because I knew you were going to
debate.
That sounds rough.
10 tenured dehydrating yourself,
but you can lose five.
But I mean like not losing muscle mass,
like just doing it the right way and
you're going to keep it off.
I'm not talking about some celebrity
crash diet or I gotta make weight for
this fight.
I mean like,
like legit.
Just how easy it is.
Fucking New York City.
He had a couple slices of pizza every
fucking night.
After a night of drinking,
you're of a certain age.
That's it.
Five pounds.
All of a sudden you fucking slacks
aren't fit in the way.
This boosting.
Yeah,
I do.
You ever do intermittent fasting?
You know what that is?
Yeah.
You ever try that?
It's called sleeping.
I haven't eaten for eight hours.
It's supposed to wait 16 breakfast break
fast.
Now I can do that.
That's not.
Fasting isn't that hard.
It's just the.
If you start at four in the afternoon
and then you know by the time you wake
up the next morning you'd gone so long
that you're not even hungry anymore and
then you kind of find and it's just that
first night and then you're already.
I know a buddy of mine does it.
He goes,
dude,
I still work out.
I don't do anything.
Goes.
I have this ridiculous amount of energy
and all this shit.
And I was just like,
I heard when you're fasting,
you're not supposed to do that.
And he's like,
it's all bullshit.
It's all bullshit.
You heard when you fast,
you not supposed to.
What exercise?
Yeah.
Like you're supposed to fucking be
chilling.
Nah,
no,
you can exercise.
You can definitely are.
Especially in a second non doctor to
tell me that I could do that.
So I'm waiting for someone with at least
has a lab coat Halloween costume to tell
me that.
I'll get dom d'agostino.
He's a guy that gets sad.
Glad God said.
We have a guy that's been on fasting.
I'd be like,
I'm sorry,
just your name.
Rhyme.
One of Gad is short for something,
but God's zoucks.
One of the great drummers of all time,
Steve Gadd,
we'll get zoucks has a great name now.
If you name your kids,
get zoucks.
It's just,
it's just not fair to you.
And she'll get zoucks is not a bad name.
It's Kinda cool.
God zoucks.
Remember that?
People would say that God souks.
I was like a comic book type thing.
Like when people were stunned,
I'd sit say [inaudible].
I would say steep.
Yeah.
Lebanon.
Common male.
Arabic name.
Given the means a felicity.
I know,
but do they fucking.
If you're last name is sad,
do you have to name your Kid Gad?
I just can't picture a part of the
world.
Will you name fucking rhymes and you
don't have to deal with that every time
I get.
Yeah,
I get it.
It rhymes.
Can I have my fucking falafel?
You want to talk to him?
He'll show.
He'll do a show.
He's funny guy.
You talked to him about that.
I don't have smart people on my podcast
ever.
You've never done it right?
I did it once.
You did do it once.
I make an exception that we did it at
place.
Okay.
Has it been that long?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well we did it.
No,
we didn't do it at my house.
We did it at the studio if I recorded it
or something like that.
Yeah.
Okay.
I like how you do a dump.
I T,
I keep telling comics saying,
look,
Bill does.
He doesn't need anybody.
He doesn't need anything.
He's got a fucking recorder and he just
rambles.
Yeah.
That's great.
That's because of my childhood,
the way you just said that.
Anybody has anybody needed anything?
He doesn't need anything.
Yeah.
That's where I went and that was my
protective place.
I went mentally.
He just started talking to yourself.
No,
I was just like,
fuck everybody.
I don't need anybody.
I don't give a shit.
I don't care.
Which wasn't true.
I did care.
But you just say,
I don't care.
I don't give a fuck.
That's a pretty common thing amongst
comics,
don't you think?
No,
I think I'm unique.
Oh,
interesting.
Now I guess it is a few guys that are
doing that now.
Like you though,
like Theo von does his podcast,
very similar to the way you do it.
He just rambles,
you know,
uh,
Dalea does it.
Very similar.
Just rambles.
But that's a great.
It's got to be a great way to develop
material.
Like,
come on,
try not to take too much shit from
there.
Uh,
you know,
I answer questions and shit.
I had my little fucking tent poles.
I got to get me through.
But uh,
I,
um,
I don't know.
I guess it just started out as a way to
promote my dates and I would just talk,
Hey,
what's going on?
I'd make a couple of jokes.
I'm going to be with the punchline in
San Francisco,
but blah,
blah blah.
And it was only like a minute long or
two minutes long and then it just got a
little long and long.
I would tell some stories.
I used to call in a service is how I did
it and it would record me on the phone.
So I had my little flip phone and I will
remember those.
Yeah,
like at an airport and talking on the
phone,
it was like a phone call and I will be
making fun of fat people and Shit.
They were walking by.
How long were those then?
Those started to get to be 10 minutes,
15 and a half hours to the point it was,
you know,
I,
I noticed I was talking on a cell phone,
like my head felt like I was getting
cooked.
Um,
and then,
you know,
and then I started like,
oh,
I need.
Oh,
I'll answer questions.
And I had to think for a while,
overrated.
Underrated.
Um,
then I had a segment,
is it racist?
But then somebody said tosh point.
Oh,
had something like that.
So I had to get rid of that.
Uh,
yeah,
just kind of did that.
Now I just,
I dunno,
I just sit down sometimes I forget that
I'm fucking
talking to anybody.
Almost all those years had just been on
the road just talking to yourself in the
car.
You talk to yourself on the road and
your car.
Really?
I listened to music.
I fucking fantasize about being in the
band as a big thing.
When I listen,
I listen to music when I listen to a
music,
like you pick any fucking song and I'll
tell you who I am in the band during it.
Like I know you an hour Smith guy.
Right?
So try and kept rolling.
I'm Joe Perry when he's fucking playing
the guitar.
And then when Steven sayings,
I'm Stephen,
I'll do the whole fantasy.
I'm just like jumping around like,
fucking I'm in Star Trek,
right?
Uh,
and then when Joey Kramer does the
fucking,
the drum roll in the middle,
that I'm joey and uh,
yeah,
I just crush it.
It's just a whole fucking fantasy of me.
Have you ever met those guys?
I met Tommy Hamilton.
Joe Perry did my podcast.
He's a great guy.
Great guy down to Earth.
Yeah.
Ridiculous with them.
You like forget this is one of the
greatest guitarists of all time.
Yeah,
all the riffs.
He wrote a regular dude.
Steven Tyler.
I'm at one time.
Yeah,
just all.
Yeah.
I always like,
um,
you know,
just that whole band experience is very,
a lot like standup where in the
beginning you're doing these impossible
gigs and you get like this,
you know,
it's like you against them and even like
as you came up as an open mic or the
band was kind of the,
the,
the class of open,
Mike occurs and you'd go up there and
you don't have to crowd got the better
you,
you'd like if you know,
if your buddy told that person to shut
the fuck up or whatever.
I just liked that whole thing.
You know,
like when I read that,
you know,
when those guns and roses books about
how their first Gig was in Seattle and
they had this van or something in a
broke down and they just kept going and
they just were thiamine and they just
somehow fucking got there at the last
second.
They just did the Gig.
Um,
you know,
I just,
and I also,
I just would think it would be,
I think it was great feeling as a
comedian to turn the room around,
but to actually be in a band and
fucking,
you know,
you did it with somebody else.
You could actually share it with
somebody as opposed to you fucking doing
it by yourself.
And then going back to the super eight,
you know,
I love that you do those gigs where you
get together early with Dean del Ray and
you guys play music and he sings.
Dean del Ray can sing his fucking ass
off.
Dude.
He's good.
Like,
he's really good.
God,
he has all the fucking rockstar moves
and shit.
He's fucking.
Yeah,
we had a great time.
Uh,
the clips he was showing you that was at
the forum and then
whole lot of rosy.
Yeah.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Like that is,
he's got a fucking voice
and we didn't tuned down.
A lot of times,
like when you go see a band you don't
really notice,
but they tuned down half a step or a
full staff and sometimes people can get
whey the fuck down on certain songs.
But he still,
I saw guns,
[inaudible] roses recently.
Actually.
Give me some volume on acts.
Here we go.
Debit on base.
Awesome.
Cover might be a little slump,
like you're a fun band together,
but you've got a legit professional
singer.
Well,
that guy on base plays in whitesnake.
That's Mike.
Devin.
She's a Massachusetts guy now.
He's a fucking beast.
He's a beast for some reason.
Everybody looks like they're playing
lefthanded there.
I had a girl I did once.
It got in a car accident with her.
Some old man ran a red light and slammed
into us.
And uh,
I uh,
cargo total.
So they're taking the car away and I
have a box in my cassettes in the car
and she sees the white snake cassette
and she fucking threw it away.
She's like,
why are you still listening to this
letter?
I let it throw it away.
She must spend beautiful.
She's pretty hot.
She was older than me.
That's why 1988 chucked my fucking white
snake.
Checked it out.
So sad.
And because of that,
somebody sent me one.
Is this still here?
Where is that?
Somebody sent me a fucking white snake
is set right in your office.
Fucking told the story and set.
Sit around here somewhere.
Someone's Wednesday here,
dude.
I feel bad.
Oh yeah.
That was first relationships.
The shit you fucking with
tolerate.
It's amazing.
I know,
I know.
But sometimes a woman.
That was the thing.
I was still kind of a boy.
She was a woman now she was 25 and she's
on her own for quite a while.
Oh yeah.
I remember when I was 23,
I dated a 30 year old.
That was not a.
That was not the way to go.
Dave.
I think they treated you like a toy.
Yeah.
And it was like,
you know,
she had been through a bunch of
relationships so she knew how to put up.
She knew how to post up in the thing,
so I was just like,
yeah,
he was ready for Ya.
Yeah,
it was fun.
She was cool and everything,
but it was just like,
yeah,
it didn't work out.
Yeah,
obviously.
Yeah.
I felt like I was a dog.
Like I was like,
I was like,
she got a dog.
No,
no chicks get a German shepherd.
No.
Yeah,
you were a German shepherd psycho.
Crazy back then to,
this is what I was.
I was still fighting,
so it was like
I was 21 and she was a graduated from
college.
Grown woman,
had a job and a career
like cds and she's like,
Oh fuck,
you know,
cassette tapes,
cds in the car is in [inaudible] 88.
Did they know they did because I
remember a buddy of mine ate a buddy of
mine.
He had the first one.
He had a Volkswagen.
Sure Aco that we thought was amazing.
Right.
That was like a sports car and he had,
this might've been 89 though.
80 nine or 90?
I can't remember.
That's kind of a blur back then so long
ago.
But he had like the uh,
they would like mountain,
like you had almost like a man.
It wasn't like in the dashboard and it
would just sit on like the little
console in the middle.
So then the thing if you went over a
bump it would skip.
Ah.
And then they had like the big suitcase
they'd put in your trunk in that way it
holds like 18 fucking cds.
Ed Changes.
Oh,
look at this.
Is that it?
Oh,
okay.
Dad Discs and 84.
Wow.
Well we were just out of high school so
he didn't have the money.
We thought he was rich.
He had a Volkswagen Scirocco oh,
it's in his car in 1984.
Wow.
You know they had car phones back in,
like the sixties,
that phones and cars.
Oh yeah.
He had to be like the presidential
level.
Yeah.
Super fucking rich guy.
I'm surprised you don't have a flip
phone.
So I would do it.
I mean,
I don't,
but I like,
I played my card games of spades and gin
rummy and shit like that.
Whenever I'm in traffic now if uber or
something,
that's how I get through traffic and I
don't flip out because I just fucking
stare at my phone.
You don't listen to books on tape or
anything like that?
No,
I can't do that.
You can't listen to books on tape.
I've never tried.
I just can't what would annoy me
listening to the person trying to make
it sound interesting,
you know,
with the influx,
with the inflections in the voice and
stuff because I'm defensive.
I like,
this guy thinks I'm a fucking moron.
And in 18,
62 data that happened that and just
talking like that,
I'd just be like,
all right dude,
just fucking read it,
read it,
read it like a bailiff,
dude.
I remember,
you know,
I have that reference because um,
when I got busted for drunk driving,
the bailiff goes,
this is what he said.
The good guy goes,
pulled the defendant over approximately
blah blah blah blah,
you know,
chasing through two towns,
whatever.
And uh,
which I,
which was bullshit,
I anyways,
I had a fucking 83 Ford ranger and the
bailiff read the thing.
He said,
uh,
the arresting officer asked the
defendant where he was coming from and
he stated fucking Boston.
And it was just like,
that's not,
that's what I said,
that's not the way I set it.
I was fucking wasted.
He,
I was trying to remember.
He said,
where'd you come from?
I was like,
fuck it,
Boston fucking Boston.
I didn't want to get out of the car.
And I was like,
yeah,
I wasn't a jerk.
But when the guy did the read,
right,
he goes,
we asked him where he's coming from.
He said,
fucking Boston.
And then I looked like a like,
oh,
it's funny,
I was standing there,
there's was all these people mug people.
And they were like laughing,
like,
oh,
this guy,
this guy's sticking it to the man.
I got
pulled over for drunk driving once,
but I wasn't drunk.
I dropped my phone,
dropped my phone in the highway,
reached down and grabbed my phone and I
wiggled a little bit right.
And I wasn't even reading my phone,
this is my phone was a treat my legs and
it fell and I thought it was going to
get underneath my accelerator and they
pulled me over and they made me do all
kinds of crazy shit and I did it.
I'm like,
I'm doing all of it.
look at me.
I'm sober.
And then they wanted me to take a
breathalyzer.
I'm like,
okay,
why do you want me to take a
breathalyzer?
Like I don't,
I don't want someone to trust your
equipment.
He just got done doing all the tests.
Like,
look,
I'm doing,
I'm on one foot and fucking pounds.
What do you need me to do?
I can,
I can do it.
Set up some cones.
Like,
do you want to know if I'm drunk?
I'm not drunk.
So why do you want me to blow in your
bullshit?
Like what's going on here?
And the cops,
they greeted with me,
they let me go,
right?
I said,
look,
I'm a big supporter of police officers,
big supporter of law enforcement.
I donate a do benefits whenever they
come up and I'm sober and I'm sober,
you know,
the best sec.
All my most of my friends,
we all got busted for drinking and
driving.
The best one was a buddy of mine.
They read his practically four in the
morning.
We noticed a Maroon VW,
Fox blowing its horn,
trying to pass on the right.
We pulled the defendant over afterwards
repeatedly asking the defendant to stay
in the car.
He got out of the car,
threw his keys at my feet and repeatedly
stated,
lock me up.
I'm fucked up.
And it was funny was my buddy was a good
looking guy and the judge was a,
was a woman and when the guy read that,
you know,
locked me up and fucked up and he wasn't
the brightest guy and he just Kinda,
when he went,
like,
he put his head down like that and he
was,
you know,
little pound puppy fucking looking dude.
And she,
uh,
she,
she gave him like a lighter sentence
because he was good looking.
I think so,
yeah.
I mean that all plays in it.
My ugly people are complaining so much
they won't take the time to develop a
fucking personality.
Right?
Some jokes do it.
The rest of us have to do like,
I don't get mad at Brad Pitt,
you know,
have it be fucking because he's fucking
beautiful.
I'm a fucking bald redheaded mail.
I know where I am in the pecking order
and some of these fucking people who are
complaining right now who are mad that
beautiful people get treated
differently.
I understand racially speaking,
but you're not going to do the beautiful
thing.
And then then that's another thing they
tried to say,
well society tries to,
you know,
they're the ones that fucking dude like,
like I love when there's a supermodel,
like did this is like an impossible
standard of beauty to try and live up
to.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's why she's on the cover of a
magazine.
She's that level beautiful.
And you're going to try and sit there
and tell me that that was learned.
But here's the
thing that's only women,
because when you see Jason Momoa playing
Aquaman,
you don't hear men say that's an
impossible standard of beauty that we
have to.
No,
I just make fun of that fucking stupid.
That trying to hang onto.
I don't care how much you can kick my
ass.
That is the dumbest.
She should be on a fucking serial box.
It's a change.
For years they had a problem like with
aqua man,
it's like he's in the ocean.
Human beings are on earth.
Like,
what do we like?
I have to see that fucking movie.
What are they going to be?
Is it going to be like Japanese people
like fitting?
He's sharp.
He goes under water.
Is that a skin like.
Well the bumps.
What is that?
Is that a suit?
Doesn't water getting the gloves have to
be all one piece.
Right?
It would be annoying as shit is any
worse than water and your glove.
So look,
it looks like it catches them like a
water catcher.
Like not just like water gets in the
gloves.
It's like a funnel.
He looks like a stripper at a
Bachelorette party.
Does a good one.
She pays money.
You got a good one.
Guy dieted down for that.
Um,
yes he did and he got all the abs so
he's been better than I am.
Oh,
you hit the button that says this is the
fall.
Look for one.
Yep.
This is when he's in the black seat.
You know what I mean?
He wants to fucking gets cold.
Yeah.
Did you see
so going on in the UK,
the UK is banned.
Advertisements that feature unobtainable
bodies is a,
I,
it recently,
the way they eat fish and chips over
there,
that's going to be most of advertising.
Well they had these ads for summer
bodies.
You know,
you see a girl in a bikini and they're
now making it illegal to
aspire to that.
Like I look at that aqua man guy that
makes me want to go to the gym and I'll
be like,
Ooh,
he's good.
Full head of hair.
Look like you got to make me feel
better.
It's because the people that complain,
who are the people that are complaining,
that people to complain to,
the people that don't want to work to be
that lady,
they don't want to work to get that kind
of a body and they want to.
They just want to not see it.
They don't want any.
They don't want to go to the subway and
see a body that they never got it.
Yeah.
I saw,
I saw an actress complaining one time
because the studio total that she needed
to lose 15 pounds and like you can't
drop 15 to star in a movie.
I mean,
what,
what Karen.
Can they specifically carrots?
Some veggies in your diet.
What do they have to dangle in front of
you to go to the fucking gym?
Like the rest of us,
like I literally like because I say,
Oh guys not to deal with that.
It's like,
yeah,
we do.
Of course.
Yes,
we do have to deal with that.
I gained 20 pounds to forget about him.
If just having five lines in a fucking
movie.
If I am north of 171 72 pounds to
fucking tweets,
I get a belly booze bag.
Hey Billy Bitch tits.
Hey Fat,
freckles.
All of this shit that I get like I know
like they,
they sit there and they had like a.
they're acting like,
like fucking preteens where everything
is just everything's about them and the
whole fucking world gives a shit.
Celebrities what they're fucking
political views is the funniest thing
ever.
It's like
all you're,
you're not,
you're not making anybody changed their
mind politically.
I think that any of that back in up,
it's like,
no,
you can't have the spotlight on you
enough.
That's all you're doing because all
you're doing with that bullshit is your.
First of all,
you're alienating half the fucking
people that are going to go see whatever
the fuck you are in.
And then secondly,
you're just getting on the radar of
lunatics in white vans with two seats
that are looking up how to fucking build
pipe bombs like that.
That's,
that's the fallout.
It's like a jerk when he goes to average
run of the mill,
son of a bitch.
And already picked Steve Martin,
the idea that a girl shouldn't be asked
to lose weight,
to look hot for movies.
Fucking crazy,
because that's what you're playing.
You're playing a hot woman and there's
part of the job
and there's millions of everybody's in
shape.
I remember fucking CNI still a bit about
this.
I saw a Ben Stiller in,
in meet the fockers or something.
There was a scene where he had to have
his shirt off in the pool.
He had fucking abs.
Then a comedy because that's because you
were seeing the influence of,
for the fucking Internet.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
you know,
he gets in your head,
people just fucking trash and you like,
I already knew I was unsightly,
but I didn't realize how many things
that people didn't enjoy it until I got
on the Internet.
I was like,
wow,
I never noticed that about myself.
So,
um,
yeah,
I don't have a look.
If somebody really has like a fucking
eating disorder,
you know,
I feel like fucking obese.
I have separately for those people.
But you 15 pounds,
20 pounds fucking and you know,
did he drink some fucking smoothies?
These women that are playing these roles
have to understand first of all,
that part of the reason why you got that
role is not just because of your acting
ability,
but also because you're pretty.
You have a beautiful face,
you were born with it,
you didn't even work at it,
and then on top of that you're supposed
to be playing a beautiful person in the
movie.
They would like you to not be fat.
Well,
there's also discrimination is millions
of dollars at stake there could be lost.
So I always feel like your job is even
if you look like me,
is to show up on time knowing your lines
in the best possible shape you could get
yourself in that.
That's the role that I.
even if I'm just fucking playing
Lang,
what if you're already laying in the.
You're supposed to play the guy that
smoking cigarettes and you're the
brother in law that's drunk all the
time.
Then your job's to look that way.
Jobs look that way.
Her job is looking at the hot woman that
everybody wants to fuck.
If they're telling you you have to lose
weight and you're,
you're a beautiful woman,
it's because they want to make you more
attractive.
It's not like discrimination.
There's a reason they want a better
product and you want to make money.
What?
I try to get a better product and I'll
tell you nothing to like really those
both male and female,
like those beautiful people at that
level.
It's like they're fucking aliens.
Like I,
I've done a couple of movies.
I did a movie one time and I remember,
uh,
it was a scene we were in a car in the
star of the movie was holding onto the
steering wheel.
And I was like,
like,
I never thought this ever bought a
woman.
I was like,
her forearms are gorgeous.
I was looking at me like I was like,
those forearms are,
but I didn't make me.
When I went to Stockholm,
Sweden,
how beautiful the people were that I was
running down the street pointing guys
with my wife.
Go near,
look at that guy.
Look at that.
That fucking guy,
like he's like an accountant walking
down the streets like does he know if he
fucking came over here,
he'd be starring in movies and that's
not all the Sweden by the way.
That's like just when you're in
Stockholm,
that's like their Manhattan,
so all the beautiful fucking people.
But I mean I went into a couple.
I went to this magnet pipe,
went and bought like a magazine or
something like that when I was over
there and the woman behind the counter
was like a fucking 11 here,
but she was working at a magazine stand.
So that was her energy.
Like,
hey,
how you doing?
I'm working in a magazine stand.
My dream hasn't come true yet.
And you just look at him like you.
You could sign
the WHO's that big model or agents?
Yeah,
like that all.
Like Cindy Crawford and all them are
with back in the day,
the Vikings,
it's Viking blood.
They the best looking people.
They,
they went over there and raped and
pillaged and all that good DNA is left
there.
They cut the best women that kept them
alive.
Killed everybody else.
Oh,
is that what happened?
Huh?
I don't know what happened.
Biking,
so that's why they're so big.
Beautiful.
Oh yeah.
No,
that's super helpful.
That's one of the funniest things ever.
When you go over to like the,
what do they call those?
The Nordic in Scandinavia is within the
Nordic countries.
I always have to remind myself that like
you'd go over there.
It was the funniest fucking shit because
it's so god damn tall.
There would be kids almost my height
whose voices hadn't changed yet and they
had the mentality of like an 11 year old
and a like,
except they was speaking that aged out
if we're talking to boys that and change
that.
And I was just sitting there laughing my
ass off because he's like fucking.
Yeah,
they like,
everybody was like,
like
a,
like six,
three,
six,
four,
five,
like rail thin with their fucking shit.
European pants.
Um,
I'm actually going over there.
Come on,
I'm stuck Stockholm next year,
but I'm going over to Europe.
I got that.
I got to run a 10,
10 days over there.
So you're doing a European tour when you
do that with three legs of three legs.
So you do three separate trips of 10
days.
Wow.
Yeah.
Just because I meeting the family or do
you just go solo?
Uh,
I'm going to bring the family on one of
them and then the other ones I'm only
gone for a little over a week,
which is a really long time when you
have a kid and it.
And it's not something that uh,
I look forward to doing now.
But it's something that it's also gives
my kid a great life.
So that's how I justify it.
So then I also,
I had to move some shit around to work
less in other areas.
But um,
that's a good balance.
I'm glad you approach it that way.
You know,
I have friends that don't,
they,
you know,
they're on the road all the time and
they have kids and you know,
there are ideas that this is what I got
to do to make a living.
I'm like,
I guess so,
but you know,
30 days in a row it's kind of crazy.
I put my kid down for a nap and like,
I'll be downstairs for like 20 minutes.
I looked at my wife,
I'm like,
dude,
I miss her.
It's just,
it's so quiet.
She's hilarious.
So it's just like a,
you know.
Um,
yeah.
And she's an unbelievable sense of humor
and uh,
yeah.
And like she would love it.
Yeah.
And I always wanted to be and I just was
afraid of commitment and all that shit.
So I waited.
I waited too long.
I did wait too long.
So,
which is why I'm going to take a fucking
sauna with you at the end of this.
We'll take us on now.
Yeah.
And I want to learn all,
you know,
ge would be really be great if there was
a company out there that could somehow
let me know.
I get a sauna in my house.
Um,
well sauna people out there.
I was working with a white snake take.
I can get a fucking get a sauna.
Sauna,
companies contact both of us.
Okay.
Because I was in contact with a guy to
do something in my fucking house in this
asshole.
Drop the ball and it's not returning
emails anymore.
So I need a new sonic company to.
I call me my free advertisement.
Where's the fucking sauna?
The Sauna Guy.
Get back to us.
No,
he hasn't gotten back to us.
Let me get the fuck them two weeks.
Should we get back to him again twice?
Got Back to this guy like trying to get
the fucking song installed in the house.
I love all those guys.
Stuff like that.
They like Comedians,
like they don't want a real job.
Contractors.
Oh yeah.
Oh the gate guy that's on a guy that,
this guy,
that guy,
they all got their little fucking in the
handyman guys.
Um,
well I grew up with those guys because
my dad was an architect so I did
construction from the time I was in high
school all throughout the summer.
I was always doing side jobs.
I always had jobs on construction sites
as a laborer.
Carpenters assistance.
I was always around those guys.
I tried to do that.
I lasted eight days.
I just,
with my fucking fair skin.
We were doing roofing and July and it
was just.
I just remember my job was I was putting
in the scaffold and going around,
you know,
when you fucking drill the hole,
then you put the triangle thing and then
you fucking put the bolt on.
This Irish guy kept going,
billy,
you must work quicker,
you much more quickly because what kept
saying to me and I finally stuck my head
out the side of the house.
I was like,
dude,
I've done this for three days.
If you want me to fucking go quicker,
you know,
we would like literally three stories
up.
And he finally shut the fuck up.
He must be a non union guy.
Uh Oh yeah dude.
I remember there was a fucking guy on
the site,
I swear to God,
he wore the same fucking jeans everyday
with like no underwear.
Right?
And it had a fucking giant fucking hole
right here on his thigh.
So I'm in fucking working in the house
and I just remember he stepped over
something with this left leg in the
whole fucking whole moved,
right?
Just like flashed his fucking junk.
I was just like.
And I did not stand up to people.
And Plus Elsie and I was the new guy on
the thing and I just was wanting to be
like,
buddy,
how about you put on some fucking boxers
or something so I don't get to look at
your fucking job.
First of all,
he's walking around with like a Goddamn
nail gun now.
Like boxers could stop that,
but any extra layer of clothing that you
could have.
This guys literally like his fucking
Shit,
you know,
like an hour.
We'll look it out of a tree
and it's burned into my head.
I could pick his junk out of a lineup.
That was the first time I ever
encountered alcoholics.
I didn't know really know about
alcoholics until I started working on
job sites and I realized that there was
guys that just had a drink your drink at
lunch that was drinking all the time and
they were always trying to quit.
I remember one guy who was like,
I'm quitting,
I'm done.
And I remember thinking,
that's good.
You got your shit together,
you know,
I was 15.
I was like,
oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
two weeks later,
fucking can of beer on the job.
I was like,
oh,
I just remember I couldn't.
Yeah,
I couldn't eat enough.
I was always hungry.
Pack two sandwiches,
three sandwiches and he just put like,
like you were the most real world
content.
Yeah,
that's what people used to do.
No,
those were like those guys.
I mean I would come home like it was
like I went to football practice.
It was just,
it just,
I,
if I stuck around for another month,
I could've gotten construction workers
shape.
I was,
but I just sucked at it.
I just didn't have it.
And then that was one of the things how
I was able to figure out what I was good
at was one of my best attributes is I
knew when I sucked at something like
take playing drums and I wanted to be an
abandoned anything.
I just went to too many music stores and
I'd see some seven year old kid and just
him starting to play or picking up a
guitar.
I just knew it.
I was just like,
I don't have that.
I don't have that gift,
you know?
Even if I played better than just the
ideas that they were already coming up
with,
um,
speaking of which do I should have
called you the other day,
I saw Dave Nevara does this thing with
his band royal machines.
It's like they just do this Christmas
show every year.
And uh,
and went with Ben Bailey the other night
at the El Rey.
Do what a fucking show these guys put
on.
Like Sebastian Bach came out and sang
highway to hell,
fucking murder.
Do Juliette Lewis,
you know,
from fucking American.
Uh,
uh,
what the fuck was that?
All the,
all the edits,
the serial killer movie with Woody
Harrelson.
Know what the fuck was that after going
natural born killers.
Although you know,
all of those fucking moved dude,
you know,
some people like I'm a comedian who
happens to play drums.
Dude,
she's a fucking Rockstar who happens to
act really?
Dude.
Oh my God.
Really?
It was so ridiculous.
I was just laughing how fucking amazing
she was.
She sang like Van Halen aint talking
about love.
And then she sang dirty deeds and it was
all just in the wheelhouse of Shit that
I listened to and I want to say she did
one more and then in the end she did
like a fucking forward somersault into
the fucking crowd.
Whoa.
It was just fucking.
Is there video this?
Um,
I dunno.
I was,
you know,
the band was so fucking good.
And then the drummers they had,
I was Josh Freese,
Chad Smith and Brad Wilk,
like,
so,
you know,
if you're into dramas,
that's just recent fucking play with
everybody.
Literally everybody,
uh,
Brad Wilk was in rage against the
machine and uh,
and Chad Smith is in the chili peppers
and those guys would just fucking
destroying.
And um,
who they had steve Stevens for,
billy idol's band was out there.
All these fucking guys.
It's just like,
wow.
Yeah.
If you get a chance they will kind of
talk.
And like it was the last year they were
going to do what?
I hope it isn't.
But Mark Mcgrath also was there who was
fucking hilarious.
He sort of like the like,
you know,
he sings the songs great,
but he's also like sort of the emc slash
comedian.
He's a really,
really naturally like funny guy.
Like he,
I would say with another comedian,
he was cracking us up.
He went on to be like an entertainment
reporter.
Right?
Yeah.
Well the thing about him is he's like,
he was either,
I feel like he was always like a self
deprecating.
Yeah.
Like he was writing hit songs,
like who the fuck can do that?
And he nicknamed an album like 1459,
like making fun,
like my 15 minutes are almost like he
was like roasting himself while he was
just writing one hit after another,
after another.
And uh,
I've gotten to meet him a couple times.
He's like one of the fucking great
people that I've met in this business.
Yeah Dude.
And he's a fucking riot.
He's a fucking funny.
Yeah.
So if you get to see guys like that and
you go,
why don't you just do stand up?
Why do you want to work these fucking
gigs?
Working for entertainment television,
pretending to give a shit about some
stupid sitcom.
Just go do it.
Well,
how much of a chance when people give
them because Oh,
you're the sugar ray guy.
Me Probably got enough shit,
you know,
like he's just one of those really like,
uh,
just this finally found some doing rage.
That was funny.
So there's Navarro that I think that's
Brad Wilk on drums,
whatever.
But he was making fun of himself before
he came out there because I forget who's
following these go like,
I know,
I know now you got to listen to the
Douche from sugary so it just totally
makes fun of himself and his love is.
Then he goes up and he fucking murders
it.
Wow.
So it's just kinda like,
ah,
I'm like,
he just reminded me of like a,
like a comedian or whatever.
So you get to hang out with Juliette
Lewis?
Um,
no.
I,
I have before.
She's cool as shit.
I want to meet her.
Oh,
she's cool too.
We've gone back and forth online
together.
I was trying to get her on the podcast a
few years ago when I dropped the ball.
Oh,
well.
I was always worried that people like
that would worry that I just want to
harp on scientology because she,
you know,
she's like a crazy scientologists I grew
up Catholic,
but what the fuck they did and still
doing.
Yeah.
No,
listen,
I hear you,
but I think she's still active to get
sensitive about that shit.
I was thinking of going back to church.
Really?
Yeah.
Just in my own way.
How you can do it.
I'm going to go,
but I'm not going to listen to anything
and I'll,
I'll,
I'll stand up and sit down.
You're to get mad if they use certain
inflections.
No,
but I'm just going to kind of go there.
It's just a place.
I don't know.
I,
I went last year with my mother in law
because she goes every weekend when we
went for Christmas mass and they had
like this New Orleans band and I was
like,
dude,
if I had this every fucking week as a
band sounded great.
I would go.
But like I,
I did,
it just sort of reminded me of like,
I used to be a better person.
I was so jaded,
you know,
I used to go every fucking week.
You think you're jaded from not going to
church or just.
I think you jaded just from knowing too
much.
Yeah.
And just,
you know,
it's just certain things just get out of
control.
You know,
what it is is when you become an adult,
you have to be your own parent,
which is weird.
Like,
hey bill,
it's time to go to bed.
Hey Bill,
lay off the booze and just the um,
you know,
just certain things just kind of get out
of whack,
you know,
almost like the mixer you life,
something's up too high or too low.
And I just felt like going there
reminded me,
you know,
so it's a nice reminder for the week,
like,
hey,
you know how,
but you're not be a for the next couple
of days.
That's what I get out of it.
I don't get like,
you know,
this guy walked on water and you know,
this is the right thing,
you know,
if you believe this,
you got to go to heaven.
And if you know,
if somebody believes something else that
go into all of that stuff,
just silly.
That's the way you put it,
as a good way of putting it,
that you have to be your own parent when
you become an adult.
That's a great way of putting it because
one of the things that you get from,
whether it's god or any kind of
spirituality,
so you get this idea that something's
bigger than you.
Something's higher than you.
There's a higher purpose and you think
about that instead of being selfish and
just thinking about
that's what it is.
You can get like a,
you know,
being a comic,
not selling tickets is one of the most
humbling things ever.
And then once you start selling tickets,
you know,
you can kinda keep,
can kind of float away a little bit and
just like,
you know,
like all the fucking bullshit that you
had to go through,
you know,
finding a flight you can afford and how
am I,
you know,
what fucking dirty cat hair car they're
going to pull up in to take them to the
comedy condo that was always cat hair,
right?
And then all of that goes away and then,
you know,
you just have this free time and like,
what are you going to do with it and
this free time and this privilege that
you have and you can really go roman
empire with it and fucking eat and drink
and smoke and be a f,
you know,
and just be a jerk,
um,
or you can,
uh,
you know,
you can still be who the fuck be as much
as who you were or whatever or trying to
help somebody out.
I just,
that's what it makes me think of when,
when I went like I was because I got so
caught up in like,
this is bullshit that never happened.
They made that up,
this is just people writing this book
and I went totally the other way.
So now I'm coming in the middle.
Like there's a reason why people do this
beyond trying to control people and make
money and power and all that.
There is,
there is something to it.
So there's a benefit for the people that
have.
Yeah.
Yes.
So
that's kind of what I was going there.
It's humbling.
It's kind of like what I left La and I'm
like never spoken to view again.
And then I started going back and they
felt it pulling me back like,
hey,
you know,
this isn't that bad.
I'm like,
ah,
fuck,
I kinda like it.
So I went back to church with my mother
in law and I was sitting there going
like,
there's an aspect of this that I liked.
I liked the sense of community.
Um,
you know,
I didn't mind the little pep talk that
the guy gives her whatever.
It would be nice
if I didn't,
didn't think if I wasn't suspicious of
them.
The problem with church is the problem
with anybody that gets in any sort of a
position of power,
it's easy to abuse it.
So the have a guy who,
a pastor that's not a creep,
that really cares and is really a good
person and really wants to care about
the community and really wants everybody
to do better and get better with life,
but isn't trying to buy a fucking Rolls
Royce like Joel Olsteen and live in a
giant mansion.
It's like
mega church.
It always goes.
It always goes south.
It's absolutely love about Joel Osteen
is he's an arena act as a preacher.
He's um,
he bought the old place,
the old arena where the,
uh,
the Houston Rockets used to play.
He bought it.
Yeah.
That's so much money that guy has.
And then he fills it up.
Yeah.
Well that was one them,
when the hurricane came,
people criticized him because he didn't
open up his doors to all the folks who
were displaced from their homes.
I was teasing them about that.
It's like you saw that electric blue
carpet he put on anything.
What do Yo,
you fucking guys getting it all wet?
No,
he does.
He has a sick ass look at that place.
Maybe it's the curtain that I thought.
Yeah.
I mean look at that fucking place.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
That looks like a dice clay special and
all those people is thrown down.
All those people are paying to be there.
Okay.
Is want to somebody out there scalping
tickets.
I got to buy the alter.
It was two ways
it right.
One is these getting all those people
together and there's a sense of
community amongst all of them.
And two is that guy's making a fuck load
of money and he's got so much power.
No,
you and all those people just at your.
But it doesn't mean you're necessarily a
bad.
That doesn't necessarily mean he's like,
what?
What can you do with it?
Which is getting the reason why I'm
thinking,
uh,
you know,
stopping in every once in a while.
Good spot.
Like they were doing that rock and roll
church thing for awhile.
There was a,
I remember one of my friends who's a
producer,
his assistant was,
she was lost.
She,
I think she,
I want to spiritually or she was lost a
lot of ways,
but she was doing this.
What's going on Jamie?
Price for what?
Four thousand $950 for the author to.
Do you want to go?
What the fuck?
Yeah,
we could do that with 1,400
bucks.
No,
no,
no.
Four thousand $950 ticket for two
tickets.
Right.
Sanction for row row.
Dod.
Dude.
For Grant and what?
That guy fucking.
That's not even if I catch the
handkerchief when he's done fucking
preaching how much I get for a row to or
not available.
Not available.
So now he's a resale tickets to know
what it is,
man.
They got fucking season passes.
People probably buy season passes to
Joel Olsteen says to tour.
This was for this.
Florida stopped.
Well,
I saw there was a place that I was at
that he was coming to one of them.
One of the big spots I was at.
He does these arena tours and he does
vegas too.
We does the fucking t mobile arena in
Vegas.
I want to see a picture of him up there.
His eyes open,
smiling and shit.
It's crazy.
It's a lot of money that guys make.
I used to say he's so full of Shit.
He can't look at the crowd.
That's eyes.
Eyes are still here.
Are they still believe in this ship when
you lie in eye contact is the toughest
fucking thing ever.
But whatever.
He's.
He's making people feel good and he's
making fuck.
He's in show business.
I want to see the show though.
He's in the God show Biz.
You have.
You have to respect an arena act I
think.
I think there's something to that.
There's something to do that.
It's a girl that was talking about.
She was lost and I think she was Jewish
or maybe she converted to Judaism later,
but anyway,
for one point in time she was going to
the rock and roll church.
She was like,
she was a sweet kid.
you should go.
You would really like it.
I'm like a guarantee.
I wouldn't like it.
I'm like,
wait.
Some young hip guy probably sing songs.
Probably tries to fuck women,
like get Outta here with that.
Right?
Like a yoga class.
It's like David Koresh.
Waco got started.
How did it get started?
Get started with one guy with a guitar
and he brought that message of Jesus and
he had some really profound things to
say and people really,
really helped them feel better.
Resonated with them.
Then he started banging people's wives
and that's what happens.
It always happens.
Yeah.
Well those rock and roll alternative
churches,
there's a few of the.
Like the Justin Bieber Guy?
No,
the guy that a justin bieber has,
he's the one that told Justin to get off
the road,
get off the road.
Justin,
come back home to Jesus like he's
getting.
He gets these guys to do a basketball
player.
Stopped playing basketball to play with.
No,
no,
no.
That guy's not doing the road anymore.
He goes back and forth.
It took a little time off or something
like the end of this tour.
Canceled his tour because of the
preacher told him it's when.
Maybe he's right though.
Let's be honest.
First of all,
bieber probably has a fucking billion
dollars in the bank and maybe he was
frayed around the edges is losing his
fucking marbles.
The kid's 21 years old.
He's about as famous as a human being.
Could possibly he only 21.
He's young.
There's the preacher will go,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
What the fucking Dick Route.
Hold up.
See what.
See what's going on with his fucking
shorts.
Brow.
No,
no,
no.
Any guy who show and Dick Route.
You know what I mean?
Like the base of your cock.
You're pulling your shorts down to base
your cock like that.
You're doing that because he's trying to
get laid.
Stop.
Pull your shorts up to a normal height.
Those things should be five inches
higher.
I know what you're doing.
Your,
your cock is slapping against your
thing.
You probably don't even have underwear
on you fucking creep.
Jesus does not want you dressing like
that.
No.
Look at them.
It's got abs,
big old,
handsome guy.
He probably Dixie chicks down for the
Lord,
right?
Dick's Dick's,
some down for Jesus and it's really
them.
Big Old,
handsome,
charismatic guy,
taking them down for Jesus.
Apparently he's a very.
He's a host.
Good Daniel with Oprah.
So you know he's legit.
They're all in the same business selling
homes.
I hope you enjoy.
Hey,
maybe he's good at it.
You know,
maybe he's got something.
Maybe helps people.
I'm suspicious.
I'm suspicious because of his shorts.
Just that alone.
That should be on the wall all over his
church.
This is me at my worst.
Well,
the worst thing you did
do what is an adult is to go out and try
and find parents again.
That's the quickest way to end up in the
trunk of somebody's fucking car.
It's fine.
Find someone to take care of you.
Yeah.
Well you see,
if you didn't see your parents didn't
pay attention to or overly coddled you,
I think.
Then you go out and you start looking
for a mom and a dad,
a mom and a dad and a mom and a dad,
and you just give away all this fucking
power.
I don't give power away to someone who
shows Dick route when they pulled her
shorts down to the base of their cock
like that.
Like as far as you can legally get your
shorts down without showing your Dick.
As long as the pubes are trimmed.
I don't think it's okay.
It's all right.
That's interesting.
Right?
It will be a problem.
Cause chaos down there and he pulled it
out.
You could see the chaos,
like basically that's,
that's.
There's a lot of pubes that you could
see right there.
You could see a lot of pubes,
but if you did it would be a real issue.
Isn't that interesting?
The same exact area is okay if you're
only seeing skin,
but if you saw pubes right there,
you'd be like,
hey man,
what in the fuck?
What are you doing that is so
not acceptable in public that like that
is a.
that's almost like the male version of a
thong guy could wear a thong but might
be worse.
But it's funny though,
Lisa,
if you have a thong on you just a freak,
right?
I'm a freak.
Oh No.
I,
to be honest with naked guy,
always funny.
It's pretty funny.
Naked.
Sure.
It depends.
Depends on the central guy.
Well,
if you're alone and somebody jumped out
of a Bush,
I mean that's fucking.
That's not a funny naked guy,
but he went back in the day when
streaking when a guy would jump out and
run across a football field.
It was the funniest.
It was just the funniest fucking thing
to tackle.
The guy now he's had it.
They always had a silly hat and they
would just start fucking running across
and I would always get me the fee.
I would.
I would tense up when I'd see them
tackle them because I would think about
his dick is raw.
Dick's smashing into the
dirt.
I saw guy,
I saw a guy when I was at Boston
University terriers game.
They don't even play soccer anymore.
Nickerson field and my fault.
My Godfather took me to the game and we
were sitting in this fucking.
Elliot was abandoned on and he was
streaking across the field and we will
fucking crying.
Laughing.
Insecurity was chasing was really fast.
He had a Bandana and like these fucking
like a date as dragons.
It was way back in the day,
right.
Getting ran across and he tried to jump
over this fucking concrete thing and he
didn't land with this junk.
It was his inner thigh on the other one.
He got over and he and as far as I know,
he got away,
but I mean dude,
it was just,
it wasn't even like,
it wasn't a nice concrete.
Was that rough unfinished shit.
And he tried to hurdle it and he got a.
He got his junk.
You got everything over and it was that
other let other leg.
Nice fucking raspberry.
It's amazing how vulnerable your Dick
is.
Dick and balls.
Just just simple,
simple trip with no pants on and slammed
down on your Dick and he horrible.
You would think there'd be some sort of
junk rib cage
to try and to try and protect it,
but it just started a turtle shell.
No,
it is.
It's just fucking just out there.
Just out there.
Yeah.
It's a terrible design and that's why
the function is.
I mean,
it has to go.
In no case you didn't notice because you
haven't been using your Dick,
you know what?
It's for it.
So it's something that someone has got
it.
Something's got to be vulnerable,
you know,
like the death star because your
temperature,
that's what it's for.
Temperature.
Your body heats up too much,
kills your sperm.
So if your balls were internal and you
were running around exercise and you'd
cook all your sperm so their balls are
hanging low on the outside.
Oh well why can't it go like in and out,
like one of those electric antennas?
Maybe in the future.
It will.
Yeah,
maybe.
Yeah.
People keep evolving.
You find a way to suck it up into your
body.
That was the thing that we always hear
about.
[inaudible],
which was a very particular hardstyle.
Karate and guys would literally get
kicked in the balls.
It would kick each other in the balls.
And the idea was that,
uh,
an under some dubious instructors.
The idea was that these guys could
actually suck their testicles up into
their body.
Like they would train to pull their
testicles up into their body.
And one day I talked to a doctor and
he's like,
that's not possible.
No,
it is like,
no.
But they think they can,
but there's some guys can develop the
ability to take a shot to the nuts.
Like there's been studies done on it.
There was a one of those,
a sports science shows.
Well these guys,
they measured like the amount of force
that a guy's throwing it at this guy's
Dick when he punched him in the Dick and
the I stand in it like this.
He lets people just fucking straight up,
punched them right in the balls and he
can take effect his dad.
It's definitely not good.
There's a trick to it.
There's certainly a trick.
The trick would be that even though you
are definitely making contact with the
balls,
really most of the forces in the taint
and the back of the ass because as you
know,
you're kicking somebody,
right?
Your foot is extends past where your
Shin is,
right?
Your Shin is here,
your foot is here.
So if your foot is slamming into the
guy's ass and taint,
it's really not.
A lot of them.
I have,
I've been kicked in the balls at least
100 times hard by grown men who know how
to kick butt like black belts.
I've been kicked in the balls so many
times because when you're sparring,
you get kicked in the balls all the
time.
I mean,
all the time you'll probably just get
used to the pace.
I thought before I had kids,
I thought I'd probably put my fucking
balls are probably totally useless.
I'm like,
I'm shooting blanks for sure.
I just thought of all the times I've
been slammed into the balls I've.
I mean I've had.
I've worn every fucking cup there is.
Especially back when I was competing.
They didn't like now they have some
pretty sophisticated cups with like
diamond mma is this cup that's got a
compression short and it sucks down into
you and it's really hard rubber on the
outside and you can actually take a good
shot to the balls and it's not going to
kill you.
But back when I was doing it,
he would get those jocks who just be a
cup that fits in a jock strap and you
pull them up and then eventually they
made some for martial arts where it just
curved under a little bit more and the
cup went back to your taint.
And the,
the downside of that was it,
it was,
there was a lot of uh,
abrasiveness.
When you're throwing kicks,
it will like rub against your inner
thigh.
And there was no compression shorts back
then either.
But I have absolutely been fucking bet
everything I have,
I've been kicked in the balls 100 times.
A No question about it.
They should take like a fucking,
you know,
like they do like a mold.
They should do a mold of your junk
custom.
They should remember that group of use
of like a mold of like all the rock
stars,
Dicks,
like a fleshlight for porn stars.
You can do that.
So they would secure.
Yeah.
I don't know.
A gross look on your face and I just.
Yeah,
I,
I get,
I get weirded out by.
I get weirded out by that shit.
Flashlights.
Yeah.
Like once this,
the non human element in gay,
you want to fuck this thing that isn't
alive.
There's just something like,
you know.
Yeah.
That's just fucking.
This is my asshole is a rubber version
of my asshole.
I.
Yeah.
I always,
yeah.
Going back in the day when you had
wanted to get porn,
you had to go into a store.
I just,
this stuff always,
it just seemed serial killer,
like body part type dehumanizing.
It's very effective though with the
flashlight was a sponsor for awhile when
I remember the days.
Yeah.
Those things were great.
I stopped using them now even though
like I try it,
I had to try it after awhile.
The listeners.
Oh yeah.
That's it only for the list.
It's very effective.
Okay.
You know about this?
What's that?
It's called ankle.
What?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
how do you not like become like,
how does that not do brain to fuck that?
Oh Jesus.
That's so disgusting.
Can you.
You think it's bad getting caught
jerking off.
Can you imagine if you swam in this foot
and 10 fucking.
First of all,
it looks real enough that you fucking
killed somebody and now you fucking.
Oh my God,
you could fuck a whole leg.
That it's crazy how realistic that
looks.
It looks like she's hanging from the
ceiling through.
This has like the skin of her heel.
It looks like it's kind of mushy a
little bit.
Right?
Like it's moving around because I want
this site might get a little weirder to
this as you can build your own mannequin
here.
So let's just get the fuck outta here.
Yeah,
we are a.
we're like,
what are you doing?
I'm in synthetics.
That's what that's called.
Synthetics.
Like parachutes and stuff.
Something like that.
Something,
something like that.
What is it?
A a one hour fucking elbow get.
No,
here's my business card.
I Dunno.
That's when I think you buy that in a
few weeks later,
you buy a giant freezer.
Just think you're going down that road.
Yeah.
It ain't good.
That's not good.
Which I honestly think like there's so
many people that had tendencies that
never when you're just living in log
cabins and shit,
like he just never were able to explore.
And I,
I feel like the same way,
you know,
I can watch all these people building
cars and stuff or you can tap into some
dark shit about yourself and uh,
you know,
the thing opens the coffin lid and sits
up and then that's in your fucking
personality.
Now it's,
it's a very,
uh,
I don't know.
I,
I try to stay away from shit like that.
Well,
especially if your kid has been abused
that I think that's the real trigger.
Real triggers.
Kids that get abused,
they get abused young and then they
developed this anger,
this hatred,
and then as they get older,
then they find these weird outlets and
then they pursue them meal now.
Yeah.
I can attest to a lot of them basically
described my fucking life.
Um,
so anyways,
we going to fucking.
Let's go get in the sauna.
Let's do it.
We'll wrap this up.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Jesus Christ.
Now be looking at your fucking foot when
I'm in there.
Yes,
please show me something else.
But I'm pretty sure neil comedy benefit,
uh,
February 19th and an amazing lineup for
the greatest live comic I ever fucking
saw.
Big Jay Oakerson.
Chris.
Read cipher sounds.
Gary Gulman,
Jim Gaffigan,
Michelle Wolf,
Rich Vos and other people that will.
I'll try to talk joe into flight out
there for it.
Uh,
in the Sada when he gets fucking hell of
a show list.
Here's one of these years.
We've got to get you out there.
I'll be happy to.
Okay.
Then F is for family season three,
season
three and streaming now on Netflix now.
God Damn.
Woo.
Alright,
thanks.
Thank you,
Joe.
Bye.